I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Lady Luck, roll those dice, it's Casino Night, everyone. Oh, baby.
我是珍娜·菲舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了这个终极版《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。女士们，我们就是《办公室》。幸运女神，摇起骰子吧，今晚是赌场之夜，各位。哦，宝贝。
Yes, it is. I'm so excited for this episode. I had not watched this since it aired until we prepped for this episode. And Angela, oh my gosh, it is so good. It is. I saw God really quickly before we get started, you guys. You know, we're recording from home right now and it's pouring rain. So if you hear some rain, that is why.
是的，没错。我太兴奋了，期待这一集好久了。自从这集播出以来，我在为这一集做准备之前就再也没看过了。天哪，安吉拉，这一集太棒了。确实如此。在我们开始之前，伙计们，我感觉自己仿佛看到了上帝。你知道的，我们现在是在家里录音，外面正下着倾盆大雨。所以如果你听到一些雨声，那就是这个原因。
Yeah, I had to move into my daughter's closet because the rain outside of my closet, it kind of sounded like I was tinkling the whole time. I didn't want it to sound like inappropriate. I mean, I know there's rain, but then you know how sometimes the rain happens to come off of a gutter in a sort of waterfall-esque way? Apparently, that's what happens outside of my closet. So I'm in my daughter's closet. Well, I'm in my, that's what she said, because all three kids are inside and they're so loud.
对，我不得不搬到我女儿的衣帽间里录音，因为我衣帽间外面的雨声听起来一直像是我在嘘嘘。我不想让声音听起来那么不合适。我是说，我知道外面在下雨，但你知道有时候雨水从排水沟流下来时，会形成一种类似瀑布的效果吗？显然，我衣帽间外面就是这种情况。所以我才待在我女儿的衣帽间里。好吧，我待在——这就是她说的，因为三个孩子都在屋里，他们太吵了。
And I'm just like, what? I can't tell them to like not make any noise ever. Yeah. Okay. So here we go. Casino night. I'm so excited. Season two, episode 22, written by Steve Carell.
我简直要说，什么鬼？我总不能让他们永远一点声音都别发出吧。好吧。那我们开始吧。赌场之夜。我太兴奋了。第二季第二十二集，由史蒂夫·卡瑞尔编剧。
Steve Carell. All right. Written by Steve Carell, directed by Ken Quapas. This is already off to a good start, Jenna. Oh yeah. This is a good team. All right. Hit me with a summary.
史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。好的。由史蒂夫·卡瑞尔编剧，肯·奎帕斯执导。珍娜，这已经开了个好头。哦，是的。这是一个很棒的团队。好吧。快给我来个剧情梗概。
Here we go. Michael decides to hold a casino night down in the warehouse to benefit charity. However, Michael is going to have to juggle two dates. Bum, bum, bum. Also Jim is dealing with his possible transfer to the Stanford branch. Yeah. And that's going to lead him to ponder his relationship with Pam. It's a good one.
来喽。迈克尔决定在仓库里举办一个赌场之夜来为慈善事业募款。然而，迈克尔将不得不同时应付两个约会对象。咚，咚，咚。此外，吉姆正在处理他可能调往斯坦福分公司的事。是的。这将促使他和帕姆重新思考他们的关系。这一集很棒。
Should we get into some Sam? Fast facts. Yeah. Fast facts. Fast fact number one, written by Steve Carell. So here's something that maybe a lot of people don't know. Steve also co-wrote 40-year-old Virgin. This is not the first thing that Steve has written.
我们是不是该聊聊“山姆”快速事实了？是的。快速事实。快速事实第一条，由史蒂夫·卡瑞尔编剧。所以这里有个可能很多人不知道的事情。史蒂夫还共同编剧了《四十岁的老处男》。这并不是史蒂夫写的第一个东西。
So he got to write this episode. You know, he also wrote another episode of The Office, season four, episode seven, Survivor Man. So we'll get to that one. But I found an old article from the LA Times where Steve did an interview all about how he came to be the writer of this season two finale. Lady, that is some good detective work. I love it.
所以他得到了编写这一集的任务。你知道的，他还写过《办公室》第四季第七集《荒野求生男》。所以我们以后会聊到那一集。但我发现了一篇《洛杉矶时报》的旧文章，里面史蒂夫接受了采访，详细讲述了他如何成为这季第二季大结局的编剧的。女士，你这侦探工作做得太棒了。我太喜欢了。
I was very proud of myself. All right. So here's how it went down. So Steve had the idea as a general episode that Michael should throw a casino night down in the warehouse. And he pitched that idea to Greg and Greg said, oh, that would make a great setting for the finale episode. And then I guess, remember when Steve had to fly to New York to do the Valentine's Day
我当时为自己感到非常骄傲。好吧，事情是这样的。史蒂夫最初的想法是作为一个普通剧集的主线，让迈克尔在仓库里举办一个赌场之夜。他把这个想法向格雷格提了，格雷格说，哦，这将是大结局剧集的绝佳背景。然后我想，还记得史蒂夫不得不飞往纽约去拍情人节
episode? Yeah. On the airplane, Steve and Greg were together and on the way there and on the way back, they sat down, they sort of plotted out together what the finale would be with this casino night idea. Because they're on the plane and they're outlining this episode. I love that. And Greg said to Steve, why don't you write it?
那一集的时候吗？对的。在飞机上，史蒂夫和格雷格在一起，在去程和回程的路上，他们坐在一起，带着赌场之夜这个创意，一起规划出了大结局会是什么样的。因为他们当时在飞机上，正在勾勒这一集的轮廓。我太喜欢这个了。格雷格对史蒂夫说，你为什么不自己写呢？
You should write it. And Steve was like, OK, yeah, I mean, I think that's great. But then this is a really fun tidbit. Steve got cold feet. And he tried to get out of it. So I guess this was during the time when he was still doing Evan Almighty on the weekends. You know, he would shoot on our show sometimes like four days a week. We would shoot him out in four days.
你应该自己写。史蒂夫当时就觉得，好吧，行吧，我觉得这挺好的。但接下来有一个非常有趣的趣闻。史蒂夫临阵退缩了。他想打退堂鼓。所以我想这是在他周末还在拍《冒牌天神2》的那段时间。你知道，他有时一周有四天都在我们的节目组拍戏。我们会在四天内把他的戏份拍完。
And then he would fly. And on the weekends, he would be doing Evan Almighty. And so he flew home and he had one weekend to write this finale script. And his parents were in town visiting him at his house. And so he went into Greg's office and he said, I just don't think I can do it justice. There's no way I can do it. I should get out of it. But Steve had this great quote where he said, I don't know, Greg managed to talk him into
然后他会坐飞机离开。周末的时候他会去拍《冒牌天神2》。所以他飞回家，只有一个周末的时间来写这个大结局剧本。他的父母正好在城里他家做客。于是他走进格雷格的办公室说，我只是觉得我无法胜任，无法展现它的精彩。我绝对办不到。我应该退出。但史蒂夫有一句很棒的名言，他说，我不知道，格雷格最终还是说服了他
doing it anyway. Like Greg has a way where by the time he was leaving Greg's office, he was like, I'm writing this episode again. How did that happen? I should not get out of it. So that makes me smile because it's very Greg. Greg, you know, we've sort of all said that he was kind of like our dad. Yeah.
无论如何要把这集写完。就像格雷格有一种魔力，等他离开格雷格办公室的时候，他心里想的已经是：我又开始写这一集了！怎么会这样？我不该退出的。这让我忍不住微笑，因为这太符合格雷格的风格了。格雷格，你知道的，我们之前都说过他有点像我们的爸爸。是的。
Although he's not old enough to be our dad, obviously, but he had sort of that father mentor thing of like, you figure it out, you're going to do it. It's going to be OK. And then you're like, wait, wait, wait, I can totally see that. I came in here to tell you I'm not doing it. But now I'm writing it. Yeah. But he did say he was really pumped.
虽然他显然没老到能当我们爸爸的地步，但他身上确实有一种父亲兼导师的气质，会跟你说：你自己能搞定，你会做好的。一切都会没事的。然后你就会想，等等，等等，我完全懂这种感觉。我本来是来告诉他我不干了。但现在我在写剧本了。是的。不过他说他当时真的很受鼓舞。
Like that was the other part of it was that Greg really infused him with this enthusiasm. So he was really excited. So what he did was he went home and he would write the script after his parents went to bed. So he would stay up at night and write the script and he turned it in and he said then the writing staff did a bunch of punch ups and like they usually do. And that's how we got the script. Wow.
这就是另一回事了，格雷格确实把这种热情注入了他心中。所以他真的很兴奋。因此他做的事就是回家，等父母上床睡觉后才开始写剧本。他晚上熬夜写剧本，然后交稿了，他说编剧团队随后像往常一样对剧本进行了一堆润色和打磨。我们的剧本就是这么来的。哇。
Way to go, Steve. Way to go. Isn't that crazy? Man, I love that story. All right. That was a good one. Moving on to fast fact number two. This is a super sized episode.
真有你的，史蒂夫。干得漂亮。这难道不疯狂吗？天哪，我太喜欢这个故事了。好吧。这个故事真不错。接下来是快速事实第二条。这是一个超长加长版剧集。
Greg said that he was doing an interview for the Chicago Tribune and he had mentioned in the interview kind of casually that he wished that the finale for season two could be super sized. Well, this started a whole online petition by office fans. They started writing in like crazy, the NBC, give me my remote, Northern Attack and Office Tally started these online petitions. And it was the fans that got us the super sized episode. That's great.
格雷格说他当时正在接受《芝加哥论坛报》的采访，在采访中他随口提到，他希望第二季的大结局能做成超长加长版。这下好了，办公室剧迷们在网上发起了请愿活动。他们疯狂地给NBC写信，要求“把我的遥控器还给我”、“北部攻击”和“Office Tally”都发起了这种网络请愿。正是粉丝们为我们争取到了超长加长版。太棒了。
And you know what? This was before Twitter and Instagram. It was not easy to start an online petition back then. Yeah. No, you didn't have the same outreach and they really just like kept at it and NBC was like, okay. And Greg was thrilled. Thank you so much to the office fans for making that happen because I could not imagine this
你知道吗？这可是在推特和Instagram出现之前。那时候要在网上发起请愿可不容易。是的。没错，当时可没有现在这样的传播渠道，但粉丝们就是一直坚持不懈，NBC最后只好妥协了。格雷格激动坏了。非常感谢《办公室》的粉丝们让这一切成为现实，因为我简直无法想象这一集
episode being 22 minutes. There's so much we would have missed. I wish this episode was an hour. I could have watched even more. I know. But I kind of feel like that about almost all the episodes. But this one in particular, I'm so happy it was longer. That's what she said.
只有22分钟。那样我们会错过太多东西了。我真希望这一集能有一个小时长。我本来可以看更多的。我知道。几乎所有的剧集我都差不多有这种感觉。但尤其是这一集，我太高兴它能更长了。这就是她说的。
That's what she said. Well, speaking of longer, this podcast is probably also going to be super sized today because well, we're going to have a special guest join us later. Ben and I got to talk to someone about this episode and this person was such a delight. Jenna, we talked for like almost an hour. We did. And we just want you guys to hear it all. So buckle in.
这就是她说的。好吧，说到更长，今天这个播客可能也会变成超长加长版，因为，嗯，待会儿会有一位特邀嘉宾加入我们。我和本有机会跟某人聊聊这一集，而这位嘉宾实在是太讨人喜欢了。珍娜，我们聊了差不多一个小时。确实如此。我们只是想让你们听到所有的内容。所以系好安全带吧。
It's going to be a super sized episode. It is. It's going to be jam packed. Bum bum bum. Wink wink. Fast back number three. We got a lot of questions from fans about what it was like to transform the warehouse into a casino.
这将是一个超长加长版。是的。内容绝对干货满满。咚，咚，咚。眨眼，眨眼。快速事实第三条。我们收到了粉丝们的许多问题，问把仓库改造成赌场是什么样的体验。
I mean, seriously, can we talk about this for a second? Can we talk about Dunder Mifflin's budget for parties? I mean, as head of the party planning committee, I usually had some streamers and a cake. I mean, and one plastic tablecloth. It's true. But then Michael takes us on a booze cruise. He throws us this casino night. Where is he getting the money for this?
我是说，真的，我们能聊一聊这个一会儿吗？我们能聊聊邓德米夫林的派对预算吗？我是说，作为派对策划委员会的主席，我通常只有一些彩带和一个蛋糕。我的意思是，还有一块塑料桌布。确实如此。但随后迈克尔带我们去坐了游轮。他又给我们办了这个赌场之夜。他这些钱是从哪儿来的呢？
At eight seconds, Jenna, you see them converting the warehouse and there's all these extra employees. There's giant neon signs. There's dealers. I mean, where is this budget coming from? That I don't know. That I don't know. But I did reach out to Kentopedia to find out how we transformed the warehouse into
在第八秒，珍娜，你能看到他们把仓库改造成了赌场，里面有各种各样的临时演员。有巨大的霓虹灯。有荷官。我的意思是，这个预算到底是从哪儿来的？这个我不知道。这个我真的不知道。但我联系了肯托百科（Kentopedia）来查明我们是如何把仓库改造成
a casino. And this is what he said. He said that he hired a company that specialized in creating casinos for special events like Christmas parties or college fundraisers. I've been to those things. I've been to fundraisers that are casino nights. Yes. So there are these companies and they send dealers, they send all the equipment.
赌场的。他是这么说的。他说他雇了一家专门为圣诞节派对或大学募捐活动等特殊活动搭建赌场的公司。我去过那种地方。我去过那种举办赌场之夜的募捐活动。是的。所以确实有这些公司，他们会派荷官来，带来所有的设备。
And so he just said he hired one of those companies and then he used all the employees from the company as extras in the episode. What was this budget? I'm sorry. I can't stop talking about the budget, but it was, it was crazy. Do you think we raised more money than the party cost? No. No.
所以他说他只是雇了其中一家公司，然后把该公司所有的员工都当作这集的临时演员。这到底是什么预算？不好意思。我停不下来不聊预算的事，但这实在是，太疯狂了。你觉得我们筹到的钱比办派对花的钱还多吗？没有。绝对没有。
It was definitely a loss. It was a loss for sure. Speaking of the whole casino setup, fan question from exploring Lauren. She asked, in between scenes, did you all play any poker games? Did you, Amj? Did you play any of the games? No. I didn't.
这绝对是亏本的。这绝对是赔本买卖。说到整个赌场的布置，这是来自“探索劳伦”（exploring Lauren）的粉丝提问。她问，在拍戏间隙，你们大家玩过扑克牌吗？你玩了吗，Amj？你玩过任何游戏吗？没有。我没有。
Did you? Oh, yeah. You did? Oh, yeah. There were any time that I was living- Well, you love poker. I love poker. I know. And it was professional dealers.
你呢？哦，是的。你玩了？哦，是的。每当我住在——好吧，你喜欢扑克。我喜欢扑克。我知道。而且那都是专业荷官。
So my character was stationed at the poker tables too. You know, whenever I was in the background of any scenes, I was sitting at a poker table and we'd play poker. It was like the greatest time, the best time. I mean, I have a memory of like sitting and watching you guys play cards because I really didn't know how to play poker. I only just learned. I'm not great.
所以我的角色也被安排在扑克桌旁。你知道的，每当我出现在任何场景的背景里时，我其实都坐在扑克桌旁，我们在那儿打扑克。那简直是超级棒的时光，最美好的时光。我是说，我有种记忆，就好像坐在那里看你们打牌，因为我其实根本不会打扑克。我当时才刚学会。我玩得不太好。
I mean, I always think I can win with a pair of threes. I'm that, I'm basically Phyllis. You can? I know. But I'm basically, you know, Phyllis, like, oh, look, the one with the flower, one. Yay. The Clovers. But a lot of you guys were poker players.
我是说，我总是觉得自己拿一对3就能赢。我就是那种人，我基本就是菲莉丝。你能赢？我知道。但我基本上，你知道的，就像菲莉丝一样，“哦，看呐，那个带花的，赢了。耶。梅花。”但你们当中很多人都是扑克高手。
I mean, Rain had a poker tournament, didn't he, in his garage or something? You guys all went? Yeah. It was the people who played the most together outside of work were me, Rain, David Denman, Chris Workman, and Ed Nielsen Jr. Those guys were on the crew. And I'm trying to think who else, but there was, there was a little group of us, like six or eight of us, and we would go to Rain's garage and play poker on the weekends.
我是说，雷恩在他的车库什么的举办过扑克锦标赛，对吧？你们都去了？对的。在工作之外经常聚在一起玩的人是我、雷恩、大卫·丹曼、克里斯·沃克曼和小埃德·尼尔森。那些家伙都是剧组工作人员。我在想要还有谁，但我们有一个小团体，大概六八个人的样子，周末会去雷恩的车库打扑克。
Yeah. So I love that you guys were doing that in between scenes. I'm sure I just was sitting there being chatty. Well, listen, I think we should take a break and get into this episode because like we said, it is, it's a long one. So we'll be right back. Okay, we are back. And let's get into this episode, Jenna.
是的，所以我很喜欢你们在拍戏间隙做这种事。我确信我当时只是坐在那里喋喋不休。好吧，听着，我觉得我们应该休息一下，然后进入正片，因为正如我们所说，这一集，它确实挺长的。我们去去就回。好的，我们回来了。让我们进入这一集吧，珍娜。
We've got a lot of ground to cover and at 36 seconds, Dwight's in a tuxedo game on. It's starting. Oh, yeah. He explains that it's a family heirloom. His grandfather was buried in it. Yeah. So that's special. And now you have a gym, Pam Prank, right?
我们要讲的内容很多，在第36秒时，德 Dwight穿着燕尾服，游戏开始了。要开始了。哦，是的。他解释说这是一件传家宝。他爷爷下葬时就穿的这个。是的。所以这很特别。现在你和吉姆有个帕姆恶作剧，对吧？
Can we talk for one quick second about the fact that Pam winks at gym with Roy or right there? I have that down. So yes, Roy and Pam, they're talking about Casino Night. This starts a whole conversation about who can win roulette. Right. Jim says he can win by using mind control, right? And Dwight says, Oh, really?
我们能花一小会儿聊聊罗伊就在旁边时帕姆向吉姆抛媚眼的事吗？我把这个记下来了。所以，是的，罗伊和帕姆在谈论赌场之夜。这引发了一场关于谁能在轮盘赌中获胜的对话。没错。吉姆说他可以通过使用精神控制来赢，对吧？德怀特说，哦，真的吗？
You can do mind control. Why don't you try moving the coat wrap? So he stares at it and it moves to everyone's surprise and then Pam winks at gym. And I wrote down, discuss how do we feel about this? It's a big wink. It's not like, and Roy is right there. Is he? Yeah.
你能用精神控制？那你怎么不试着移动那个衣帽架呢？于是他盯着它看，在所有人的惊讶中，衣帽架居然动了，接着帕姆向吉姆抛了个媚眼。我当时就记下了：讨论一下，我们对此作何感想？这是一个很大的媚眼。这可不是那种——而且罗伊就在旁边。他真的在吗？是的。
Does he not have eyes? Is he not? Yeah. Is Roy looking at his fiance? What the hell? Why are you winking at gym? So the flirt is starting early on. This is early.
他难道没长眼睛吗？他不在吗？对啊。罗伊难道没在看他的未婚妻吗？搞什么鬼？你为什么对吉姆抛媚眼？所以调情从一开始就展开了。这可是刚开始。
For sure. Early in the evening. It's not even the evening. It's the day. The flirt is starting. I had a fan question from Batya who said, was the wink Pam gave Jim scripted? Yes, it was. I was going to say, absolutely.
肯定的。夜幕还没降临呢。这还是白天。调情就已经开始了。我收到了巴佳（Batya）的一个粉丝提问，她说，帕姆给吉姆那个媚眼是剧本里写好的吗？是的，是的。我本来想说，绝对是的。
It was. It was in the script. I actually, I have the script from this episode, Angela. I love that you have the script. So you could go to it. Yeah. I looked it up and it's right there. It says Pam winks at gym.
是的。剧本里就是这么写的。我实际上有这一集的剧本，安吉拉。我太喜欢你留着剧本了。所以你可以去查证。是的。我查过了，上面写得清清楚楚。上面写着“帕姆向吉姆抛媚眼”。
I had another fan question too from Brittany in the cold open, Jenna, did you actually move the coat rack with an umbrella? No. No. No. And Jenna, what? In a time capsule called the DVD commentary. You talk about it.
我也收到了来自布里特妮（Brittany）的另一个粉丝提问，在开场白中，珍娜，你真的是用雨伞移动了那个衣帽架吗？没有。绝对没有。珍娜，什么？在一个被称为DVD花絮的时光胶囊里。你谈到过这个。
Oh, I went into it. Yeah. You went into it. You said that there was a crew member that had a string. It was like a clear like fishing line. We tried to have me do it. We tried to have me use the little, even like tried to have me use that string thing. And you just saw my arm moving too much.
哦，我深入讲过。是的。你详细讲过。你提到剧组有个工作人员手里拿着一根绳子。那是一种透明的鱼线。他们试图让我自己来做。他们试图让我用那个小东西，甚至试过让我用那个带绳子的东西。但你只能看到我的胳膊动得太厉害了。
I was too far away. Like the, the umbrella with the hook on the end, it couldn't, I couldn't even reach the coat rack with it. I was going to say the coat rack is actually further away from you than people realize. Yeah. It's actually quite far from you. But the optical illusion makes it kind of seem like I could have, but no, I wasn't really doing it.
我离得太远了。就像那个带钩子的雨伞，它根本——我甚至用它够不到衣帽架。我本来想说，衣帽架其实比大家想象的要离你更远。是的。它其实离你相当远。但光学错觉让人觉得好像是我弄的，不，其实真不是我干的。
And then Pam is very proud of herself because she has a silent talking head where she's showing off the umbrella and Jenna, you're like as Pam, you are beaming, you're so proud of that moment. I know. Well, I think it's meant, you know, that wasn't set up that whole idea of mind control. I think the idea of that was that in the moment, Pam figured out how to have Jim's back. Yeah. And so I think she's like, that's where the wink comes from and that's why she's so
然后帕姆为自己感到非常骄傲，因为她有一个无声的访谈镜头，镜头里她在展示那把雨伞，珍娜，作为帕姆的扮演者，你当时简直笑逐颜开，你对那个时刻感到无比骄傲。我知道。嗯，我想这是有意安排的，你知道的，整个精神控制的想法并不是真的。我觉得这个想法的含义是，在那一刻，帕姆想出了如何成为吉姆的后盾。是的。所以我觉得媚眼就是这么来的，这也是为什么她会如此
proud. Exactly. She's super proud. They didn't know Dwight was going to pick the coat rack. Pam didn't know that Jim was going to set that up. No. Yeah. She's like, look what I did.
骄傲。没错。她超级骄傲。他们当时并不知道德怀特会挑中衣帽架。帕姆也不知道吉姆会设下那个局。没有。是的。她就像是在说，看我做了什么。
Oh my God. I know. I had another fan question, Angela. This is from Chelsea Glover. Were there any deleted scenes that your sad didn't make the final cut? And actually there is an original cold open to this episode. This little prank bit with the coat rack, this was actually originally meant to go after the credit sequence and there's a whole cold open that was cut out, but that you can see
天哪。我知道。我还有一个粉丝提问，安吉拉。这是切尔西·格洛弗（Chelsea Glover）问的。有没有什么删减片段是你们觉得很可惜没能进入最终正片的？实际上这一集原本有一个最初的开场白。用衣帽架搞的这个小恶作剧桥段，原本其实是打算放在片头演职员表之后的，有一个完整的开场白被删掉了，但你们可以在
on the DVD extras. Did you watch it, Angela? It's where Michael brings us into the conference room and makes us do a Dunder Mifflin themed madlib. Madlibs. Yes. It's great. Yeah.
DVD花絮里看到。安吉拉，你看过吗？就是迈克尔把我们带进会议室，让我们玩一个邓德米夫林主题的“疯狂填词游戏”（Mad Libs）。疯狂填词游戏。是的。很棒。是的。所以我觉得这挺酷的，但我们当时时间不够，所以不得不把它剪掉了。好吧，听着，我有一个相当重大的发现要指出来。我敢肯定你们很多人都在想这件事。你们肯定会讨论它。这算是一个让人眼前一亮的惊艳时刻。是什么？
So I thought that was kind of cool, but we had enough time, so we had to cut it out. Well, listen, I have a pretty big thing to point out. I'm pretty sure a lot of you guys were thinking about it. You're going to be talking about it. It's kind of a showstopper moment. What is it? At three minutes, one second, there's a new plant at reception, a new potted plant. There is a yellow flowering plant at reception.
在3分1秒时，前台多了一株新植物，一盆新的盆栽。前台那里有一株开黄色花的植物。这可是个大事，伙计们。我们收到了关于这个的超多邮件。我们根本没收到关于这个的任何邮件。每当帕姆带来一株植物时，我总是忍不住大笑，我觉得这就是帕姆买了一株植物，然后它活不了多久，但她尽力了。这就是我的背景设定。她尽力了，就像赌场之夜一样，我会从你知道的药店买一盆植物。他们在结账区摆着那些植物。
This is a big deal, guys. We got so much mail about this. We got no mail about it. I always crack up whenever Pam, I feel like it's Pam brings in a plant and then it doesn't live very long, but she tries. That's my backstory. She tries to, it's like casino night, I'll buy a plant at the, you know, at the pharmacy. They have those plants by the checkout.
她尽力了。她试图给前台带来一些欢快的气氛。好吧，我们来看看迈克尔和简打电话的那场戏。她试图解释她对分公司现状的担忧，但他直接邀请她来参加赌场之夜。而她说，迈克尔，她是在为分公司担心，而他却想办一个花钱如流水、极其奢华的派对。
I'll buy one. She's doing her best. She's trying to bring some cheer to the reception desk. Well, we have the scene where Michael is on the phone with Jan. She's trying to explain her concerns about what's going on with the branch, but he just invites her to casino night. And she's like, Michael, she's concerned for the branch and he wants to have this elaborate party that costs so much money.
是的。而简的反应就是，迈克尔，我才不——我才不去那那种地方，不过也许以后再说别的吧。好吧，接下来在4分11秒，迈克尔在办公区。他坐在帕姆的桌子上。她正在解释说我们要举办赌场之夜，受益机构是美国童子军，当晚的头奖获得者将获得500美元，以捐给自己选择的
Yeah. And she's just like, Michael, I'm not, I'm not coming to that, but maybe later, something else. Okay. So next up at four minutes, 11 seconds, Michael's in the bullpen. He's sitting on Pam's desk. She's explaining that we're having casino night, that the beneficiary is Boy Scouts of America and that the big winner of the night is going to get $500 to donate to the
慈善机构，还有一个由万斯冷气赞助的小冰箱。是的。菲莉丝对此感到无比骄傲。天哪。超级骄傲。如果你把画面定格在4分34秒，菲莉丝的脸，她其实把舌头都伸出来了，她太高兴万斯冷气能赞助这个奖品了。但在我们聊到那儿之前，我必须为那些一直收看节目的观众指出4分14秒的一个绝佳截图。
charity of their choice and a mini fridge compliments of Vance refrigeration. Yes. To which Phyllis is so proud. Oh my gosh. So proud. If you freeze at four minutes, 34 seconds, Phyllis's face, she actually sticks her tongue out, she's so happy that Vance refrigeration is donating the prize. But before we get there, I have to point out a great screen grab at four minutes, 14 seconds
我谈论过我所谓的“会计矩阵”。这就是他们如何把会计部门的人堆叠在一起把他们塞进办公区的，对吧？因为我们被挤在拐角周围。所以你本来是看不到我们的。所以他们会把我们以这种队形拉出来，那是我见过的关于这个的最佳截图，那就是我和奥斯卡在复印机旁，奥斯卡就离我大概两英尺远，然后布赖恩在奥斯卡后面大概三英尺远。
for those of you guys that have been tuning in. I talk about what I call the accountant stack. It's how they stack the accounting department to get them in the bullpen, right? Cause we're tucked around the corner. So you wouldn't see us. So they would pull us out in this formation and it's the best screen grab of it. I have seen yet it is me at the copier with Oscar, just like two feet behind me and then Brian like three feet behind Oscar.
我们看起来简直就像一排多米诺骨牌，这样我们就能入镜并做出反应了。这简直绝了。我记得他们会这么做，有时候这完全没道理，明明其他人都能坐在自己的办公桌前听迈克尔说话，但你们这群人却不得不站起来，稍微走过去一点，全程站在复印机旁边。是的。每当看到其他人能舒舒服服地坐在那儿听超长的戏时，我就会羡慕得不行，因为我们
It is like literally we look like a row of dominoes and it's so we could be in the scene and react. And that is perfect. I remember that they would do that and sometimes it would make no sense that everyone else was able to sit at their desks and listen to Michael, but you guys would have to get up and walk over a little bit and stand and bring them up by the copier the whole time. Yes. I would be so envious of people that got to sit through really long scenes because we
只能一直站在复印机旁。哦，对于重温这些剧集的人来说，知道会计们经常站着而其他人坐着，这也是个挺有意思的细节。然后我们就进入了一系列访谈镜头，每个人都在镜头前解释如果自己成了当晚的大赢家，会把钱捐到哪里去。你知道的，克里德有一个访谈镜头，他说他要把钱捐给一个
just be standing by the copier. Oh, that's a good thing when you're rewatching these episodes for people to just know how often the accountants are standing up. Yeah. While everyone else is sitting. So then we lead into this series of talking heads where everyone explains where they would donate the money should they be the big winner for the night. And you know, Creed has a talking head where he says he's going to give the money to a
周四供应超美味豌豆汤的流浪汉收容所。哦，克里德。克里德。凯文说捐给动物或人，再次提醒我们他可能真不是最聪明的人。安吉拉，你有一个很棒的访谈镜头。
soup kitchen. Yeah. That has a really delicious pea soup on Thursdays. Oh, Creed. Creed. Kevin says to animals or people, once again, reminding us that he is maybe not the smartest person. Angela, you have a great talking head.
太有腔调了。我一点也不想参加这个赌场之夜。我说我们这不就是直接在送赌博赢来的钱吗。我们怎么不直接去贩毒或者卖淫呢？是的。把那些钱直接捐给慈善机构算了。我知道她很不爽。
So much sass. I am not wanting to participate in this casino night. I say that we're just going to be giving money. That's from gambling. Why don't we just deal drugs or prostitute ourselves? Yeah. Just give that money to charity. I know she is.
我敢肯定她不高兴是因为她没能策划这个派对。其次是因为有赌博还有酒精，但珍娜，她最后还是现身了。好吧，她待会儿还是会出现在这个赌场之夜上。是的，她去了。这就引出了我最喜欢的场景之一，里面有我这辈子听过、有史以来最喜欢的台词，绝对是史上最佳。我知道你想说什么。我知道你要说什么。
I'm sure she's a not happy because she's not getting to plan this party. B is gambling and there's alcohol, but Jenna, she shows up. Well, she's going to show up later to this casino night. Yeah, she does. So this leads into one of my favorite scenes with some of my favorite lines of all time ever from the series, ever. I know what you're saying. I know what you're going to talk about.
迈克尔宣布，在今晚结束时，他们将向一些童子军颁发一张巨型支票。他兴奋极了。太符合他的风格了，对吧？他为能发出一张巨型支票而感到高兴坏了。而托比却说，哦，其实，迈克尔，并非如此。然后他列举了许多不适合让小孩子来参加赌场之夜的理由。
Michael announces that at the end of the night, they're going to present a giant check to some Boy Scouts. He's so excited. That's so him, right? He's so delighted that they're going to have a giant check. And Toby's like, oh, actually, Michael, that's not true. And then he lists the many reasons why it would be inappropriate to have kids come to a casino night.
他说有赌博、酒精，在一个危险的仓库里，而且还是上学前夜，还有猫头鹰餐厅（Hooters）提供餐饮服务。我还需要多说吗？是的。我还需要继续往下说吗？这就引出了迈克尔的经典台词。你为什么偏偏是现在这个样子？迈克尔式的嘲讽，我记下了：迈克尔的嘲讽，迈克尔的嘲讽。
He's like gambling, alcohol, it's in a dangerous warehouse, it's a school night, Hooters is catering. Do I need to say more? Yeah. Do I need to go on? So this leads to the classic Michael line. Why are you the way that you are? Michael Sass, I wrote Michael Sass, Michael Sass.
接下来这句台词绝对是我的最爱，安吉拉。我无比痛恨你骨子里选择成为的那种人。我当时根本没办法顺畅地把这话说完。所以迈克尔说的所有这些——“你为什么偏偏是现在这个样子？”所有这些都是剧本里写好的。台词本上一个字不差。太棒了。然后迈克尔宣布，他要将钱捐给“患有艾滋病的阿富汗人”（Afghanistanis with AIDS）。
This next line is my most absolute favorite, Angela. I hate so much about the things that you choose to be. I could not get through that. So that whole thing that Michael says like that, why are you the way that you are? All of that was scripted. It's in the script word for word. So good. Then Michael announces that he is going to donate to Afghanistanis with AIDS.
但我们收到了来自奥古斯塔（Augusta）的粉丝提问。她说，我这辈子最喜欢的场景之一绝对是“阿富汗人”那场戏。这里面有哪部分是即兴发挥的，还是全都是剧本写好的？好吧。我去查了剧本，基本上全是剧本写好的，除了有一句台词，那是约翰·卡拉辛斯基即兴发挥的。他本来应该只说“阿富汗人”（Afghans）。
But we got a fan question from Augusta. She said, one of my absolute favorite scenes of all time is the Afghan, Afghanistanis scene. Was any of that improvised or was that all scripted? All right. I went to the script and it's mostly all scripted with the exception of one line, which is John Krasinski. He improvised Afghanistanis. He was supposed to just say Afghanistanis.
真有你的，约翰。干得漂亮。真会为整段对话画上圆满的句号。真会收尾。珍娜，我得跟你聊聊在7分31秒发生的事。哦，是的。因为吉姆主动提出要和帕姆一起看那些糟糕的婚礼乐队，她高兴坏了。天哪。
Way to go, John. Way to go. Way to put a button on it. Way to put a button on it. Jenna, I need to talk to you about what happens at seven minutes, 31 seconds. Oh yeah. Because Jim offers to watch crappy wedding bands with Pam and she's so happy. Oh my gosh.
她太高兴了。好吧，她本该跟罗伊一起做这事的。我是说，她说本来是罗伊要选乐队的，但他现在忙着策划自己的单身派对呢。我的意思是，一个人到底需要多少个红灯警示信号？我不知道。她居然在跟一个不是自己未婚夫的、她暗恋的男人一起策划婚礼。是的。
She's so happy. Well, she should be doing this with Roy. I mean, she says Roy was going to pick the band, but now he's too busy planning his bachelor party. I mean, how many red flags does someone need? I don't know. She's planning her wedding with the guy she's in love with that's not her fiance. Yeah.
然后吉姆说出那句让你心碎的话。在第8分钟时，他说，我的意思是我跟简谈过调职的事，因为我在（斯克兰顿分公司）没有未来。是的。他在那儿根本没有未来。我知道。我知道。所以现在他们去——你知道的，我们稍微跳跃了一下，但让我们把这个吉姆和帕姆的
And then Jim has the line that breaks your heart. At eight minutes, he says, I mean, I talked to Jan about a transfer because I have no future here. Yeah. He has no future there. I know. I know. So now they go, you know, we're jumping around a little, but let's see this Jim Pam
时刻看完吧。好的，女士。好吧。他们在会议室里，看着这些乐队的录像。顺便说一句，我们收到了大量关于布赖恩打鼓的提问。是的。超多人都写信来问。是的。
moment through. Okay, lady. All right. They're in the conference room, they're watching these band videos. By the way, we got a ton of questions about Brian's drumming. Yes. So many people wrote in. Yes.
所以他们放了一段磁带，然后意识到，哦天哪，那是凯文。是的。凯文在一个乐队里。你猜“Scrantonicity”（斯克兰顿幻觉）这个乐队名字是谁想出来的？谁？明迪。真的吗？是的。
So they put in a tape and they realized, oh my gosh, that's Kevin. Yeah. Kevin is in a band. Guess who came up with the band name Scrantonicity? Who? Mindy. Really? Yeah.
那是明迪想的。那是明迪。那是她的主意，那个名字。所以我们来看看这个。当我查看剧本里的这一幕时，乐队的名字其实不叫Scrantonicity。哦，真的吗？叫什么？“Jokers and Tokers”（笑匠与烟枪）。
That was Mindy. That was Mindy. That's that was her idea, that name. So we'll check this out. When I looked at this scene in the script, the name of the band is not Scrantonicity. Oh yeah. What was it? Jokers and Tokers.
所以我给布赖恩发了信息，因为我们收到了很多关于他是不是真的在打鼓、是不是真的在唱歌的问题。是的。而且我也必须弄清楚这个“笑匠与烟枪”到底是怎么回事。布赖恩告诉我，他在视频里其实是在演奏和演唱一首史蒂夫·米勒的歌，我的意思是他说自己在弹，但其实他是在假弹，因为他当时根本不会打鼓，直到后来他的乐队必须去演出时才真正学会。是在菲莉丝的婚礼上吗？
So I texted Brian because we got a lot of questions about is he really drumming, is he really singing? Yeah. And I also had to get to the bottom of this Jokers and Tokers business. Brian told me that he is actually playing and singing a Steve Miller song in the video and I mean he says he's playing but he's really kind of faking it because he didn't really learn to drum until later when his band had to play. Was it at Phyllis's wedding?
对的。他当时必须上台，对吧？是的。所以他是在硬着头皮假装把那首歌混过去。所以在他们拍完他和乐队的整场戏后，他们没能获得史蒂夫·米勒的授权来使用那首歌。所以在后期制作中，他们把乐队变成了一个“警察乐队”（The Police）的致敬乐队，也就是在那时他们把名字改成了Scrantonicity，而且布赖恩不得不给自己的歌声配音，唱的是《别靠近我》（Don't Stand So Close to Me）。
Yeah. He had to be on stage, right? Yeah. So he's kind of faking his way through the song. So after they shot this whole scene of him and his band, they could not get permission from Steve Miller to use the song. So in post, they turned it into a police tribute band and that's when they changed the name to Scrantinicity and Brian had to dub his voice singing Don't Stand So Close to Me.
这就是他们最后播放出来的版本。所以如果你看那个视频，歌词其实根本对不上他的嘴型。不过直到布赖恩告诉我这些事之前，我根本没注意到这点。哦，那挺有意思的。根据这些背景知识，我还捕捉到了一些其他的小细节。注意在9分43秒时，有一个约翰把磁带放进录音机的手部的特写镜头，上面写着Scrantonicity。我记得那是后来补拍的。
And that's what they ended up playing. So if you watch that video, the lyrics do not match his mouth. I didn't notice it until after Brian told me all this stuff though. Oh, that's good. And I caught a couple of other little tidbits based on this knowledge. Notice that at 9 minutes 43 seconds, there's a close-up of John's hand putting the tape into the tape player and it says Scrantinicity. I remember shooting that later.
我记得当时不得不补拍一个约翰把Scrantonicity放进去的手部特写镜头。好的。然后在后来的仓库里，你知道的，罗伊走到凯文面前对他说，嘿，我听说你的乐队叫Scrantonicity了，对吧？这发生在22分5秒。是的。乐队的名字是在镜头外说出来的。那是罗伊的声音。
I remember having to do a pickup of John's hand putting in Scrantinicity. Okay. And then later in the warehouse, you know, Roy is going to come up to Kevin and he's going to say, hey, I heard about your band Scrantinicity, right? This happens at 22 minutes and five seconds. Yeah. The band name is said off camera. It's Roy's voice.
但镜头拍的是凯文，他们连这个都不得不后期配音。关于Scrantonicity，这可真是一些不错的幕后花絮啊，女士。我知道。谢谢你，布赖恩·鲍姆加特纳。好的。我们跳跃得有点快，但回到8分16秒，达里尔来到了迈克尔的办公室。他的意思是，听着，我绝不在造纸仓库里搞什么喷火艺人。
But on camera is Kevin and they had to dub that too. That was some good behind-the-scenes tidbits for Scrantinicity, lady. I know. Thank you, Brian Baumgartner. Okay. So we're jumping around a bit, but back at 8 minutes 16 seconds, we have Daryl in Michael's office. He's like, look, I'm not having fire eaters in a paper warehouse.
那他为什么要在赌场之夜找喷火艺人呢？我跟你讲，如果可以的话，他甚至想在里面铺满整个冲浪板。他想搞得更大、更吵、更疯狂。然后德怀特为了所谓的“保护”登场了。接着有一段非常搞笑的对话，我们得知达里尔教了迈克尔一些短语来帮他应对跨种族对话。我们知道了“Dink和Flicka”，Dink和Flicka，这是一个击掌手势。达里尔有一个很棒的访谈镜头。
So why does he want fire eaters at a casino night anyway? Let me tell you, he would have a full surface in there if he could. He wants it bigger, louder, crazier. And then Dwight enters for, quote, protection. And then there's this very funny exchange where we learn that Daryl has taught phrases to Michael to help him with his interracial conversations. We learn about Dink and Flicka, Dink and Flicka, this handshake. And Daryl has a great talking head.
而且珍娜，我很确定这绝对是克雷格·罗宾逊在本剧中的第一个访谈镜头。我觉得是的。好吧，安吉拉，我在城市词典（Urban Dictionary）上查了“Dink和Flicka”。真的吗？哦，是的。里面提到《办公室》了吗？是的。
And Jenna, I'm pretty sure that this is Craig Robinson's very first talking head, I think in this episode. I think it is. Well, Angela, I looked up Dink and Flicka on Urban Dictionary. You did. Oh yeah. Does it reference the office? Yes.
上面说它是在《办公室》最近的一集里被带火的，“Dink和Flicka”大致翻译过来就是“这就是生活”或者“随它去吧”。我依稀记得讨论过这个，Dink和Flicka，而且那是史蒂夫现编的。我不知道我记得到底准不准，但我觉得这绝对是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔自己脑洞大开想出来的。还有“fleece it out”（搞定它/放轻松）。这也是另一个。
It says made popular in a recent episode of the office, Dink and Flicka roughly translates to that's life or say lovey. I sort of remember that as talking about that, Dink and Flicka, and that Steve had just made it up. I don't know if I'm remembering that long, but I think that is just out of Steve Carell's mind. Also fleece it out. That was another one.
那个也在城市词典里。我挺喜欢这两个自创短语现在作为虚构短语被收录进城市词典里的。真有你的，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。干得漂亮，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。好了，接下来有一些非常精彩的帕姆式嘲讽。哦，是的。好吧。
That's also in the Urban Dictionary. I kind of love that these two made up phrases are now in the Urban Dictionary as sort of fictional phrases. Way to go, Steve Carell. Way to go, Steve Carell. Well, there is some delicious Pam Saths coming up. Oh yes. Okay.
我太喜欢这个桥段了。这是我们节目里最让我喜欢的那类情节：我们发现了一个秘密，原来某个角色多年来一直在做某事，而我们以前竟然不知道，这就是其中高光时刻之一。所以在10分58秒，卡瑞尔太太打来电话，帕姆说，迈克尔，卡瑞尔太太来电话了，接着她做了一件事，她没有立刻把电话接通。她嘴里念叨着：还是我，还是我。
All right. I love this bit so much. This is one of the things our show did that I love where we find out information that something a character has been doing for years, but we didn't know it, and this is one of those moments. So at 10 minutes 58 seconds, Carell stills calls, and Pam's like, Michael, Carell's on the phone, and she does this thing where she doesn't let it through right away. She's like, still me, still me.
是的，因为她必须这么做。她说迈克尔在第二次拨通时表现得更好。他在跟人打第二通电话时状态更好。因为第一次他说了一些荒唐可笑的话，你把它写下来了吗？他第一次对卡瑞尔太太说了什么？他说，嘿，卡瑞尔，房地产生意怎么样，是不是真的很棒？帕姆在一旁念叨：还是我。然后第二次，他就完全正常了。
Yes, because she has to. She says Michael is better at the second attempt. He's better at his second pass with people. Because the first time he says some ridiculous thing, did you have it written down? What does he say to Carell the first time? He says, hey, Carell, how's the real estate biz, is it real good? Pam's like, still me. And then the second time, he's totally normal.
是的，他就像是：嘿，卡瑞尔，怎么啦？太棒了。接着同样的事情又发生了。这是一场很棒的戏。所以迈克尔在和卡瑞尔太太通电话，她只需要他为房屋抵押保险签最后字。这就是她打电话的原因，但他却对卡瑞尔太太说，你应该来参加赌场之夜。而她反应是：哈？为了拿签字去你的派对？他问的问题有点让人摸不着头脑，
Yeah, he's like, hey, Carell, what's up? It's so good. And then the same thing happens. This is a great scene. So Michael's on the phone with Carell, and she just needs one last signature for his mortgage insurance. That's why she's calling, but he tells Carell, you should come to casino night. And she's like, yeah, to get the signature, it's a little confusing what he's asking,
对吧？南希把那个角色演得太棒了。我当时就想：等等，去你的派对？在那儿拿签字？是的。我们应该提醒大家伙儿，卡瑞尔太太是由南希·卡瑞尔饰演的，也就是史蒂夫现实生活中的妻子。然后另一条线，帕姆正在转接另一通电话，打来的是简。
right? And Nancy did such a great job with that. I've just been like, wait, to your party? That's where I get the signature? Yes. We should remind people, guys, Carell stills, played by Nancy Carell, Steve's wife in real life. So then the other line, Pam's putting through another call, it's Jan.
哦哦。简打电话来告诉迈克尔，迈克尔，我很乐意去参加赌场之夜。我觉得你可以看到史蒂夫饰演的迈克尔，简直急得满头大汗。是的，他心里在想：天哪，我怎么会有生以来第一次在短短几秒钟内让两个都在电话里对我说“好”的女王同时出现在赌场之夜？我得想办法推掉一个，哦天哪，这可真是个巨大的悬念。这就直接进入了通常的商业广告插播时间。
Uh-oh. Jan is calling to tell Michael, Michael, I would love to come to casino night. I feel like you can watch Steve as Michael, like literally break into a sweat. Yeah, he's like, holy crap, when in a million years did I think that I'd have two women on the line who'd both just said yes to me within seconds of each other to Queens on casino night? I'm going to have to drop a noose, oh boy, so that's a big cliffhanger. We go into like what would normally be a commercial break right there.
我们是不是该进一段广告了？我们进广告吧，因为接下来我们要进入赌场环节了，而且会有很多很多事情发生。好的，我们回来了，我们现在身处赌场。赌场开业了，赌博正在进行中。开门迎客。但是在13分22秒，好戏上演了，珍娜，你身上穿的那条裙子可真够醒目的。天哪，为了这个特意盛装打扮了一番。
Should we go into a break? Let's go into a break because now we're going to get into the casino game and a lot, a lot is going to happen. All right, we are back and we are at the casino. The casino is open, gambling is happening. It's open for business. But 13 minutes, 22 seconds, it is happening, Jenna, you are wearing quite the dress. Oh, my God, very dressed up for this.
我们收到了大量关于你这条裙子的邮件。马特·梅布（Matt Mabe）问：在你决定穿身上这件蓝色裙子之前，你到底试穿了多少条不同的裙子？丹尼·瑟古德（Danny Thurgood）说：我妻子有个理论，说帕姆穿的这条裙子是帕姆衣柜里的一条旧伴娘裙。丹尼，我在卡片上写下了：“帕姆穿着伴娘裙？问号”，这看起来真的很像伴娘裙。确实很像。
We got a ton of mail about your dress. Matt Mabe said, how many different dresses did you try on before you settled on the blue one that you wore? Danny Thurgood said, my wife has a theory that the dress Pam wears was an old bridesmaid's dress that Pam had in her closet. Danny, I wrote on a note card, Pam in a bridesmaid's dress, question mark, it really looks like a bridesmaid's dress. It really does.
是的。然后原版格斯女孩（original Gus girl）问：帕姆穿礼服时戴着手表是谁决定的？这是一个微妙但绝佳的服装和角色设定选择。我喜欢所有这些问题。你们大家的观察力太强了。首先我要说，安吉拉和丹尼的妻子，你们猜对了。这真的是一条伴娘裙吗？
Yes. And then original Gus girl said, whose decision was it for Pam to wear her watch with her gown? It was a subtle but great costuming and character choice. I love all of these questions. You guys are so observant. All right, let me start by saying Angela and Danny's wife, you guys are correct. Was it a bridesmaid's dress?
嗯，当我跟我们的服装设计师凯莉（Carrie）开会讨论帕姆在这集的着装时，这就是灵感来源。我们当时说，你知道的，我们希望她能穿得像件鸡尾酒礼服一样盛装出席。但以帕姆的薪水以及对她生活的考量，她什么时候才会去买一件鸡尾酒礼服呢？而且她绝对不会为了一个赌场之夜专门去买一件。所以我们进行了一场大讨论，最后觉得，你知道的，我觉得她大概是重复利用了一条旧伴娘裙。
Well, that was the inspiration when I met with Carrie, our wardrobe designer, about this outfit that Pam would wear. We said, you know what, we want her to be dressed up in like a cocktail dress. But on Pam's salary and just thinking about Pam's life, when would she ever buy a cocktail dress? And she's certainly not going to buy one just for casino night. So we had a whole conversation where we were like, you know what, I think she rewears an old bridesmaid's dress.
那是她衣柜里最奢华的衣服了。于是她就穿了那件。我得让你们知道，那是我试穿的第一件裙子。我们一眼就爱上了。她当时有一整排裙子，我都试穿了。那一件是我们的最爱。我们把照片发给了格雷格，他立刻就批准了。从一开始这就是个大赢家。
That's the fanciest thing she has in her closet. And that's what she wears. I'll have you know, that was the first dress I tried on. We loved it. She had a whole rack of dresses and I tried them all on. That was our favorite. And we sent that picture to Greg and he approved it immediately. It was like a winner from the start.
哦，这太棒了，太完美了，完美解答了我内心深处一直想问的问题。因为当时我就在想，那个——我觉得我也穿过一条看起来跟那差不多的伴娘裙。90年代参加婚礼时穿的。顺便说一句，安吉拉，我超喜欢那个关于手表的提问，因为那确实是我们讨论过的事。这是我们讨论过的一个细节：帕姆每天都戴着那枚手表，大多数时候你看不到它，但每天菲尔·谢伊（Phil Shea）都会走到我面前，他拿着一个小托盘，
Well, that is so great and perfect and really answers my burning question. Cause I was like, that, I feel like I wore a bridesmaid's dress that looks similar to that. Yeah. To a wedding in the 90s. By the way, I love that watch question, Angela, because that was a discussion. It was a discussion that Pam wears that watch every day, most of the time you can't see it, but every day Phil Shea would come up to me and he had a little tray and it had
上面放着我的手表，还放着我的帕姆结婚戒指或者帕姆订婚戒指。你拿起来，一大早把它戴上，深夜结束时再摘下来。所以其实我一直都戴着那块手表，但你平时看不到，因为它们被我的袖子挡住了，对吧？所以我们当时进行了整场讨论：帕姆穿着这身华丽的礼服时到底该不该戴手表？最后我们觉得，听着，伙计们，这可是iPhone普及之前的年代。那时候你可没办法像现在这样把时间揣在裤兜里。
my watch and it had my Pam wedding ring on it or my Pam engagement ring on it. And you pick it up, you put it on first thing in the morning, take it off at the end of the night. And so I've always been wearing that watch, but you cannot normally see it because it's underneath my sleeve, right? So we had a whole discussion, does Pam wear her watch with her fancy dress or not? And we thought, listen, guys, this is back before iPhones. You didn't have the time in your back pocket the way you do now.
而且我们讨论过，帕姆并没有什么奢侈的手表。所以她只有一块手表，她就戴着它。我简直不敢相信居然有人注意到了这个细节。谢谢你们的细心观察。帕姆会戴着她的手表，这对我来说太合情合理了。我太喜欢了。我觉得她可能还在旁边备了一双Keds帆布鞋，随时可以换上。我太爱了。
And we discussed that Pam does not have a fancy watch. So she's got one watch and she wore it. And I can't believe someone noticed that detail. Thanks for noticing. Pam would wear her watch that made such sense to me. I love it. I feel like she also probably has a pair of Keds on standby that she can change into. I love that.
安吉拉，你的裙子呢？你穿着一条黑裙子，这很符合你的色彩搭配，但我意思是，这稍微有点，有点什么？挺性感的，还有点紧身。绝对是一条LBD（小黑裙）。确实是条小黑裙。我的事业线确实有点若隐若现。稍微有一点。
Angela, what about your dress? You're wearing a black dress, which is in your color scheme, but I mean, it's a little bit, it's a bit, what, sultry, it's somewhat tight. It's an LBD for sure. It is a little black dress. I mean, I have a little bit of cleavage. Yeah. A little bit.
有一点。确实是一条紧身小黑裙。我觉得她可能是穿着它去参加过葬礼，也许领口原本还带有一些蕾丝花边，但也许她今天感觉有点、有点风骚。所以她当时想：我才不穿那件配它的毛衣呢。其实我还真有一件毛衣在剧情里进进出出。我不知道你们有没有注意到，一开始我在手里拿着它，过一会儿你又看到我穿上了。
A little bit. It is a tight little black dress. I feel like she probably wore it to a funeral and maybe it had some lace attachment over her decotage, but maybe she's feeling a little, a little saucy. So she was like, I'm not going to wear this sweater that goes with it. I do have a sweater that comes in and out of scenes. I don't know if you noticed at right at the top, I'm holding it and then later on you see me wearing it.
不过是的，我知道我穿的是一条小黑裙。我得指出来。我有点扯远了，但我捕捉到了一个绝佳的角色破功瞬间，而那个破功的人就是13分24秒时的我。有一个安吉拉·马丁跟梅丽迪斯说话的镜头，你会发现在这个瞬间刚开始时，也许我是意识到镜头正摇过来，所以我摆出了一副严肃的表情，然后很明显，我以为镜头已经移开我们了。接着我就开始，直接开始手舞足蹈，我觉得我嘴里好像在说“我要去上厕所”或者类似的话。天哪，还有什么其他状况吗？你是不是还在另一个镜头的背景里？
But yeah, I know I'm wearing a little black dress. I have to point out. I'm jumping around, but I have a great catch of someone breaking character and that someone is me at 13 minutes, 24 seconds. There is a shot of Angela Martin talking to Meredith and you see at the very beginning of the moment, maybe I'm aware that camera's panning over and so I have a solemn look and then clearly I think camera has gone off of us. And then I just go, I just like start gesturing and I think I can make out the words I have
我在你和罗伊赌博的那个建立镜头的背景里。然后镜头摇向了我们其他人。吉姆在另一张桌子旁，我在跟梅丽迪斯说话，我手里拿着毛衣，在那个镜头的最开始，我是一张严肃脸，然后在几秒钟内，我以为镜头已经拍完了。我就开始自顾自地聊天。百分之百全是我在闲聊。天哪。好吧，我们现在该进入正片了吗？我们开始吧。开始偷筹码。
to pee or something. Oh my gosh, what else is going on? Are you in the background of another scene? I'm in the background of an establishing shot of you and Roy gambling. And then it pans over to the rest of us. Jim's at another table, I'm talking to Meredith, I'm holding my sweater and at the very beginning of it, I have a solemn face and then within seconds I think the camera's gone. I just start being chatty.
卡尔来了，德怀特大概是迈克尔的僚机，然后托比刚刚在牌桌上赢了迈克尔。是的。我收集到了几个关于这些情节的粉丝提问。第一个来自杰西卡·默克纳（Jessica Merkner）。
It's a hundred percent me just talking. Oh my gosh. All right, should we get into it now? Let's get into it. Let's get into stealing poker chips. Carol has arrived, Dwight is Michael's wingman, I guess, and Toby just beat Michael at cards. Yes. And I have a few fan questions about that stuff.
她说德怀特是个糟糕的僚机。他没能及时警告迈克尔简要来了，这太搞笑了。这里面有即兴发挥的成分吗？好吧。我去查了剧本，你知道当卡尔刚到，德怀特跑过来时——
The first one comes from Jessica Merkner. She says Dwight is a terrible wingman. His inability to warn Michael that Jan is coming is great. Was any of that improvised? All right. So I look at the script and you know when Carol first arrives and Dwight comes up? And says, code remax is here, but no sign of Land Jevenson. Yeah.
他说：“代号雷马克（Remax）来了，但完全不见兰杰文森（Land Jevenson）的踪影。”太棒了。后面那句是即兴发挥的。所以我不太确定。太棒了。我知道。我不确定那是雷恩自己发挥的，还是现场编剧给的提议，因为我们现场会有编剧给我们提意见，贡献笑话。但原本台词应该是“不见第二个约会对象的踪影”，这也挺搞笑的，因为这不仅一点都不像代号，而且还大声嚷嚷出来。
It's so good. That second part was improvised. So I'm not sure. That's so good. I know. I'm not sure if Rain did it or if it was like one of the writer pitches on set because we would have writers on set that would pitch us jokes. But the original line was supposed to be no sign of date number two, which is also very
他说迈克尔有第二个约会对象。好吧，珍娜，在18分26秒，我有一个叫“亲吻、一巴掌、某种默克”的卡片。这绝对是经典桥段。这是德怀特和安吉拉的经典时刻。当时德怀特正在玩双骰子赌博（craps），安吉拉穿着她的小黑裙走了过来，问道：“你在干嘛？”
funny because it is in no way coded and also out loud. He says Michael has a second date. All right. So Jenna, at 18 minutes, 26 seconds, I have a card called Kiss Slap some Merk. Oh, this is a classic. This is a classic Dwight Angela moment. It's when Dwight is playing crafts and Angela walks up in her little black dress and she's like, what are you doing?
他们俩之间显得非常正式。你知道的，非常正式。然后他说：“安吉拉，我需要摇出一个8，大家就都赢了。”她回答说：“那就摇出一个8呗。”结果他还真摇出来了。是的。他激动坏了，一把抓住你，在你的脸颊上亲了一口。我知道。
And they're very formal with one another. You know, very formal. And he's like, Angela, I need to roll an eight and everyone wins. And she says, so roll an eight. And then he does. Yes. And he is so excited that he grabs you and he kisses you on the cheek. I know.
听着，尽管她可能对此挺高兴的，但她还是得因为他在工作场合行为不端而扇他一巴掌。是的。好吧，安吉拉，我们收到了来自希瑟·林多（Heather Lindo）的粉丝提问。山姆，能放一下这段音频吗？嗨，珍娜。嗨，安吉拉。“赌场之夜”是我最喜欢的剧集之一，原因有很多。
And listen, even though maybe she's happy about that, she has to slap him for being inappropriate at work. Yes. Well, Angela, we got a fan question from Heather Lindo. Sam, will you play it? Hi, Jenna. Hi, Angela. Casino Night is one of my very favorite episodes for a lot of reasons.
其中之一就是双骰子赌博桌旁的那场戏，德怀特为了好运亲了安吉拉。接着她扇了他一巴掌，但当她转过身时，她的表情简直完美绝伦。她在短短大约三秒钟内循环表现了大概十种情绪。她既惊恐又激动、既尴尬又显然内心深处无比开心，所有这些情绪同时存在。我太喜欢了。安吉拉，我的问题是，你是一条过（one take）搞定的，还是拍了非常非常多次？
And one of them being the scene at the craps table when Dwight kisses Angela for good luck. And then she slaps him, but when she turns around, her face is just perfection. She cycles through like 10 emotions in a matter of like three seconds. She is horrified and thrilled and embarrassed and obviously deep down very happy all at the same time. And I just love it. Angela, my question is, did you nail that on the first take or did you have to do it many, many times?
非常感谢让我有机会提问。我知道每个人都这么说，但我和我姐姐金（Kim）真的是《办公室》的头号粉丝。我们太爱你们了。非常感谢你们。天哪，希瑟。这也太甜了吧。我太喜欢这个提问了。好吧。
Thank you so much for letting me ask my question. I know everyone says this, but my sister Kim and I really are the Office number one fans. We just love you so much. So thank you. Oh my God, Heather. That was so sweet. I love that question so much. Okay.
我听到这个问题时兴奋坏了，因为我当时真的在日记里写下了关于这场戏的记录。天哪。你果然写了。
So I was very excited about this question because I actually wrote in my journal about this scene. Oh my gosh. Of course you did. I wrote about it the week we filmed it to answer your question. Heather. No, I did not get it right the first time. Okay.
我就在我们拍那周的日记里写了，来回答你的问题，希瑟。不，我可不是一条就顺利通过的。好吧。
So I wrote that I was really nervous to slap Rain at first, you know, my slap was kind of timid, which makes sense because you were probably very, you were worried about hurting him. Exactly. I don't want to hurt him. And it wasn't a fake slap. They told you to really slap him. That was, they were never did a phony slap.
所以我写道，一开始我真的很紧张要扇Rain耳光，你知道的，我的动作有点羞涩，这也是情理之中，因为你可能很担心会弄伤他。没错。我不想弄伤他。而且那不是假打。他们要求你真打。那是，他们从来不做虚假的耳光。
No, they wanted a real slap and well, I guess my timid little slap wasn't working. So Rain said, listen, Ange, just go for it. I can take it. So I started really slapping him. Oh no. And I wrote that it took us about 13 takes to get. Oh no. Yes.
不，他们想要一个真实的耳光，好吧，我想我那种害羞的小耳光没起作用。所以Rain说，听着，安吉，直接上吧。我承受得起。于是我开始真的扇他。哦不。我写道我们大概拍了13条才过。哦不。是的。
Yes. That's 13 slaps. All right. Here's the one thing I need you guys to remember. I am 5'1". Rain is like 6'3". So it wasn't really easy for me to reach his cheek. And one time my aim was really off and I missed his cheek and I slapped his ear so hard.
是的。那是13记耳光。好吧。这里有一件事我需要你们记住。我身高5英尺1英寸。Rain大约6英尺3英寸。所以要让我够到他的脸并不容易。有一次我的准头真的偏了，我没打到他的脸，而是重重地扇了他的耳朵。
He was like, I'd actually heard him. He said there was like a ringing in his ear. And then the other time I missed and I, I slapped and I hit his glasses and I knocked them sideways on his face. I know. I know. Well, I want to go back to something that Heather said too about that look on your face as you're walking away because it is, it is amazing.
他当时说，我其实真的弄疼他了。他说他的耳朵里有耳鸣声。还有一次我打偏了，我挥手扇过去却打到了他的眼镜，把眼镜打得在他脸上歪向了一边。我懂。我懂。不过，我想回到海瑟之前说的关于你走开时脸上的那个表情，因为那个表情，那个表情太棒了。
And I have the script and I looked it up and all it says is that you slapped Dwight and that you smile as you walk away from the table. I think there's so much more going on in your face. So your character is angry that Dwight would kiss you so publicly and all of that. But what I love is that you have this little look to the camera at the very end. It's like 18 minutes, 48 seconds, where you sort of catch the camera catching you smiling. Right. That camera catch was not in the script.
我有剧本，我查过了，上面只写着你扇了德怀特，而且当你从桌子旁走开时你笑了。我觉得你脸上的戏份要丰富得多。所以你的角色对德怀特竟然当众亲吻你感到生气，诸如此类。但我最喜欢的是，在最后快到18分48秒的时候，你冲镜头露出了那个小表情。就像是你突然发现镜头拍到了你的笑容。对。那个面对镜头的瞬间并不是剧本里有的。
Was that improvised? Yes, it was. Okay. So that, that just happened on the day, that little moment where I'm busted at the end. So in one of the early takes, I was walking out of frame and I just looked at camera and I quickly looked away. Like I was embarrassed that they caught me smiling and our director of photography, Randall Einhorn said, Angie, Angie, I caught it.
那是即兴发挥吗？是的，是即兴的。好吧。所以那个时刻就是那天顺其自然发生的，就是最后我被抓包的那个小瞬间。所以在早期的一次拍摄中，我正走出画框，我只是看了一眼镜头然后迅速移开视线。就像是因为被拍到微笑而感到尴尬，我们的摄影指导兰德尔·爱因霍恩说，安吉，安吉，我抓到了。
I caught it right at the end as you're leaving frame. And he really helped me find that moment. Then he showed it to our director, our director loved it. And so Randall was like, Angie, you don't have a lot of time to cycle through all that, but I'm going to catch it every time if you've glanced the camera and quickly look away embarrassed. So I have to thank Randall for that because he really helped me make that moment happen. I love that. Yes.
我在你离开画框的最后关头抓拍到了。他真的帮我找到了那个瞬间。然后他把它拿给我们的导演看，我们的导演很喜欢。所以兰德尔就说，安吉，你没有太多时间去展现所有这些情绪，但如果你瞥一眼镜头然后又尴尬地迅速移开，我每次都会把它拍下来。所以我必须感谢兰德尔，因为他真的帮我促成了那一刻。我太喜欢了。是的。
All right. So out there that love background catches, I have one more moment for you in this little scene at 18 minutes, 51 seconds, you can really see how red the side of rain spaces. And it's because I have slapped him 13 times. Well, there you have it, Heather. Thank you for such a great question. Thank you, Heather. I love that question.
好吧。对于喜欢捕捉背景镜头的观众，我在这场戏里还有一个精彩瞬间留给你们，在18分51秒时，你们真的能看到Rain脸的一侧有多红。那是因为我扇了他13次。好吧，事情就是这样，海瑟。谢谢你提出这么棒的问题。谢谢你，海瑟。我很喜欢那个问题。
Okay. Angela, you just described the big kind of Dwight Angela flirt moment that happens in front of everybody at the, at the casino night. So now we head over to the poker table where it is heads up between Jim and Pam. And I feel like this is the big Jim Pam flirt moment that's public. There is so much flirting happening. Pam is basically doing the giggle hair toss move from about last night. I mean, there it is on.
好吧，安吉，你刚刚描述了德怀特和安吉之间的大型调情时刻，就发生在赌场之夜所有人的面前。现在我们走向扑克桌，那里是吉姆和潘的单挑对决。我觉得这是吉姆和潘公开的大型调情时刻。里面有太多的调情了。潘基本上在做着大约从昨晚开始的傻笑甩头发的动作。我是说，它正在上演。
Well, we had a fan question from live love, California, the scene at the poker table when you and John are making those faces back and forth. Was that improvised or scripted? This is what was scripted. Those little looks between us. There was a scene description. And so what you're seeing is John and I's interpretation. This is what it says right after Jim's line, you're bluffing.
嗯，我们收到了来自“加州爱与生活”的粉丝提问，在你们和约翰在扑克桌前眉目传情的那场戏里，那是即兴的还是剧本写的？剧本是这样写的。我们之间的那些眼神交流。当时有一段场景描述。所以你们看到的是我和约翰的演绎。吉姆的台词“你在虚张声势”后面紧接着这样写道。
Pam makes a playful gesture like, who knows? Jim stares at her intensely. She smiles her best enigmatic smile. Jim enjoys this woman so much he finally has to break eye contact and shake it off. Oh, so that was what John and I, we had to take that note in the script and that's what made that scene. Oh, that's so good. I love that.
潘做了一个顽皮的手势，好像在说：谁知道呢？吉姆热烈地凝视着她。她露出了她最好的神秘微笑。吉姆太喜欢这个女人了，他最后不得不打破眼神接触并甩掉这个念头。哦，所以这就是我和约翰所经历的，我们必须领会剧本中的那个提示，正是这一点成就了那一幕。哦，太棒了。我喜欢这个。
Yeah. I love that. Well, I have a question that's not related to you guys flirting, but at 19 minutes, 26 seconds. So Kevin wears glasses when he plays poker, but he doesn't wear glasses to be an accountant. Angela, we literally got a fan question that said the same thing. What's up? My theory about that is that he doesn't care about being an accountant.
是的。我喜欢。嗯，我有一个和你们调情无关的问题，但在19分26秒。凯文打扑克时戴着眼镜，但他当会计时却不戴眼镜。安吉，我们真的收到了一个粉丝提问，问了完全相同的事情。怎么回事？我对此的理论是，他根本不在乎当什么会计。
I know. But as he tells us, he has won one of the satellite games in the World Series of Poker. He's an avid poker player this guy. He's a different person when he's playing poker. He's a smart person when he's playing poker, but also when he's playing in his band, he wears a hat. I know. Like when he comes to the barbecue, he's got a hat.
我知道。但正如他告诉我们的，他在世界扑克大赛中赢过一场卫星赛。这家伙是个狂热的扑克玩家。他在打扑克时完全是另一个人。他在打扑克时是个精明的人，而且当他在乐队里演出时，他也戴着帽子。我知道。就像他来参加烧烤派对时，他也戴着帽子。
He's got a whole persona outside of the office that is very different than what we see on a daily basis. Oh, for sure. For sure. I want to follow this guy around. I feel, is he, is he putting us all on so that he doesn't really have to do work? What's happening, Kevin? Okay.
他在办公室之外有着一整套人格，与我们日常看到的非常不同。哦，绝对是。绝对是。真想跟着这家伙转转。我觉得，他是在糊弄我们大家，好让他不用真正工作吗？凯文，到底怎么回事？好吧。
We have to talk about 20 minutes, three seconds, Carol and Jan are now side by side at the bar. Oh yeah. Okay. So I took a screen grab of them standing side by side. You know I'm friends with Nancy, Steve's wife. I just adore her so much. I texted her the photo and I'm like, Nancy, this is how I'm starting my morning.
我们必须谈谈20分3秒，卡罗尔和简现在并肩坐在吧台旁。哦，是的。好吧。所以我截了一张她们并肩站立的屏障。你知道我和史蒂夫的妻子南希是朋友。我太喜欢她了。我把这张照片发给她，我说，南希，这就是我开始早晨的方式。
And she was like, oh my God. She said, first of all, WTF with my hair. I said, Nancy, what do you remember about shooting these scenes? And she said, oh my gosh, well, our kids were six and three, so I had very few functioning brain cells at that point. And I said, well, Nancy, what was it like working with Steve? And she said, Angie, I was so intimidated because he's so good. I mean, he was really nice to me, of course, but I've sort of, you know, I had retired
她说，哦，天哪。她说，首先，我的发型是怎么回事。我说，南希，你对拍摄这些场面有什么记忆吗？她说，哦天哪，好吧，我们的孩子当时六岁和三岁，所以我当时几乎没有什么正常运转的脑细胞了。我说，好吧，南希，和史蒂夫一起工作是什么感觉？她说，安吉，我当时感到非常畏惧，因为他太棒了。我的意思是，他对我真的很好，当然，但我有点，你知道的，我已经退居幕后了
and having our kids, that's what I was doing. I was being a mom, so I felt a little rusty, but it was so much fun. Oh, she is so great. And Steve's face would just light up every time she came to set, either if she was in a scene or if she was just coming by with the kids for a visit. I mean, his adoration of her was just, would go all across his face. Oh. They just were the cutest of cutie-cutes as a couple.
还要照顾我们的孩子，这就是我当时在做的事。我在当妈妈，所以我感觉有点生疏，但真的非常有趣。哦，她太棒了。每当她来到片场，无论是客串一场戏还是只是带着孩子顺道来拜访，史蒂夫的脸都会瞬间亮起来。我的意思是，他对她的爱慕之情全都写在了脸上。哦。他们作为情侣简直是可爱本尊。
They are an adorable couple. They are so sweet with one another. I just loved them so much. I would get so excited too when Nancy got to be in scenes because we were often in hair and makeup at the same time, and we would just gab and gab and gab. I just adore that lady. So now Michael is at the craps table, and he has both Carol and Jan blow on the dice for luck.
他们是一对令人喜爱的情侣。他们彼此非常甜蜜。我太喜欢他们了。当南希能参演时我也会格外兴奋，因为我们经常同时在做发型和化妆，我们会不停地闲聊。我太喜欢那位女士了。现在迈克尔在掷骰子桌旁，他让卡罗尔和简都在骰子上吹气来求好运。
So awkward. So weird. So weird. And then this is where Dwight starts peppering Jan with questions about where are you staying tonight? He's naming all the motels. And then Dwight has this line where he's like, oh, were you planning to stay with Michael? Well, that was not in the script.
太尴尬了。太诡异了。太诡异了。然后就在这里，德怀特开始用问题轰炸简，问她今晚住哪儿？他把所有的汽车旅馆都点名了一遍。接着德怀特有一句台词是这样的：哦，你是打算和迈克尔住在一起吗？好吧，那可不在剧本里。
Oh, it wasn't? No. No. I feel like that, when I heard that, I went to the script to look because I'm like, that sounds like a rain improv to me. That's brilliant rain. So good. So good.
哦，没有吗？没有。没有。我觉得当我听到那句话时，我去查了剧本，因为我在想，听起来这像是Rain的即兴发挥。Rain太才华横溢了。太棒了。太棒了。
So I'm giving that to rain. And Malora's reaction. Yes. So good. I think she was legitimately surprised that he said it. Yeah. I texted Malora. I told her she's so fantastic in this episode.
所以我要把这个归功于Rain。还有玛洛拉的反应。是的。太棒了。我想她对于他说出那句话是真的感到了惊讶。是的。我给玛洛拉发了短信。我告诉她在这集里她太出色了。
You just really feel Jan's desperation. And then you feel herself loathing. It's, oh, it's so layered. So now we go over to the poker table with Kevin and Phyllis. Mm-hmm. Phyllis the flapper. Oh boy. Phyllis the flapper.
你真的能感受到简的绝望。然后你能感受到她对自己的厌恶。哦，真是充满层次感。现在我们走向凯文和菲莉丝所在的扑克桌。嗯哼。摇摆女郎菲莉丝。哦天哪。摇摆女郎菲莉丝。
Phyllis the flapper. He goes all in against Phyllis and she wins with a flush. But she thought she only had ace high. But no. Phyllis the flush to the ace and she is like, I have all the clovers. I texted Phyllis and I said, Phyllis, what do you remember about that poker game? And she wrote me and said, oh, I loved the poker game. Brian's face is Kevin was priceless when I won.
摇摆女郎菲莉丝。他全押对上了菲莉丝，而她以同花顺赢了。但她以为自己只有A高。然而并没有。菲莉丝拿到了A同花顺，她说，我拿到了所有的梅花。我给菲莉丝发短信说，菲莉丝，你对那场扑克游戏有什么记忆？她回信说，哦，我太喜欢那场扑克游戏了。我赢的时候布莱恩也就是凯文的表情简直无价。
And then she wrote, I also loved watching Pam and Jim Flirt as they played because it looked real because they're such good actors. Oh. Oh, I know. She's the sweetest. She's the sweetest. She's the sweetest. She said it was a priceless episode.
然后她写道，我也很喜欢看潘和吉姆在打牌时调情，因为看起来太真实了，因为他们是那么优秀的演员。哦。哦，我懂。她最甜了。她最甜了。她最甜了。她说这是一集无价的节目。
My love to you and Jenna. Aw. Well, listen, you know what? Jan is going to walk outside at 22 minutes 37 seconds because she is just over it and she's outside smoking and Jim walks out. And Lindy, I don't know if you remember this, but at the time when this aired, so many people thought that Jim and Jan were maybe going to hook up in this moment and they were freaking out on all the message boards.
代我向你和珍娜问好。哦。好吧，听着，你知道吗？简在22分37秒时要走到外面去，因为她实在受够了，她在外面抽烟，然后吉姆走了出去。琳迪，我不知道你是否还记得，但在这一集播出的时候，很多人以为吉姆和简可能会在这个时刻发生点什么，他们在各大论坛上都快急疯了。
Oh my God. Yeah. I remember like, oh no. Oh no. Are they going to hook up? But no. They're just having a heart to heart. And then you find out the stakes for Jim, right?
我的天。对。我记得当时想，哦不。哦不。他们要在一起了吗？但并没有。他们只是在推心置腹。然后你发现了对吉姆来说这意味着什么，对吧？
That he, she's like, have you told anyone because he's going to transfer. But people thought they might hook up and they were all like, no. Yeah. So now we go back inside. Bob Vance is making an announcement. He is going to announce who the big winner of the night is. He said, it's Creed Bratton and he wins a refrigerator and Creed says, I've never owned a refrigerator.
那就是他，她说，你告诉别人了吗，因为他要调走了。但人们以为他们可能会在一起，然后他们都觉得，没有。对。所以现在我们回到里面。鲍勃·万斯正在宣布消息。他要宣布今晚的大赢家是谁。他说，是克里德·布拉顿，他赢了一台冰箱，克里德说，我从来没拥有过冰箱。
Oh my God. This is his first one. The mini fridge is his first refrigerator. So here we go guys. We are to the jam-tastic part of this episode. There is going to be a big moment in the parking lot. There's going to be a big moment in the office. So we thought we better call John Krasinski.
天哪。这是他的第一台。迷你冰箱是他的第一台冰箱。所以各位，我们到了这一集的“咸甜”部分。停车场将有一个大场面。办公室里将有一个大场面。所以我们觉得最好给约翰·卡拉辛斯基打个电话。
That's right. We didn't feel like we could talk about these scenes without him. So we did. We called him and he joined us. So guys, this is like we chitty chatted with John for a good 45 minutes. We're going to let it play out here for you. Enjoy. Guys, I watched an office episode for the first time in so long for this.
没错。我们觉得没有他我们就无法讨论这些场景。所以我们打了。我们打电话给他，他加入了我们。所以大家，这就好像我们和约翰闲聊了足足45分钟。我们在这里把它播出来给你们听。尽情享受吧。伙计们，为了这次节目，我好久没有看一集《办公室》了。
I haven't watched one for a little while now and that one in particular, that's some heavy machinery of content. That was some heavy machinery. We just threw you in the deep end, John. We were like, here. Watch this one. Yeah, seriously. And I was like, first of all, I went through a time portal.
我有一段时间没看过了，尤其是那一集，那简直是内容重工业。那真是重工业。我们直接把你扔进深水区了，约翰。我们就好像，给你。看这一集。是的，说真的。然后我就想，首先，我仿佛穿越了时空隧道。
I was like, who is that child? And I was talking about Jenna and then I saw some furry, you know, wood nymph come in looking at me. Man, we were young once, weren't we? Wasn't that nice? Yeah. Well, man, that was nice way back then. This is the first time I've watched Casino Night since it aired.
我在想，那个孩子是谁？然后我看到一些毛茸茸的，你知道的，森林仙女走进来看着我。天哪，我们曾经也很年轻，不是吗？那不是很美好吗？是啊。天哪，过去那感觉真好。这是我自《赌场之夜》播出以来第一次看它。
Same. Yeah. Did we watch it at Greg's? I think we did. We did. We did. I wrote in my journal that he had a viewing party and we all went over. Oh my God, you have a journal?
一样。对。我们是在格里格家看的吗？我想是的。我们看了。我们看了。我在日记里写过，他举办了一个观赏派对，我们都过去了。天哪，你还有日记？
What am I doing with my life? Does she have a journal? Let me show you what my mic sits on so I can reach it because I'm shorty. Like seven journals. Like with Holly Hobby on the front. John, that's who I was. Oh my God. Wait, who you were, that seems like a current journal that is being written about right
我的人生都在干什么？她有日记吗？让我给你看看我的麦克风放在什么上面，这样我才能能够到它，因为我是个小不点。大概有七本。封面上还有霍莉·霍比。约翰，我就是那样的人。天哪。等等，你过去是那样，那听起来像是一篇关于当下的日记
now. I'm writing right now. By the way, speaking of Holly Pocket or whatever, Holly Hobby, either one of those E's, they made me think of that kid sister thing before I signed on. I was like, I had all these like sputtering memories that were like, remember this? And I blacked out for about 20 minutes. Okay. So I told on the podcast that we would do bits between scenes, kind of keep us going,
现在正在写。顺便说一句，说到霍莉·波基或者别的什么，霍莉·霍比，不管是哪个E，它们让我在签约前想到了那个妹妹的事情。我就像，我脑子里有所有这些零星的记忆，就像，还记得这个吗？我大概断片了20分钟。好吧。我在播客上说过，我们会在场景之间做一些小搞笑环节，算是让我们保持状态，
that you really kept us all going. You really did. And then I said, we would do this kid sister, big brother bit. And Jenna was like, wait, where did that come from? What was that about? I was like 1883 is where it came from. I know. But John, wasn't it because there was like a doll that was about my height?
你真的让我们所有人都保持了状态。你确实做到了。然后我说，我们要扮演这个妹妹、大哥哥的角色。然后珍娜就说，等等，这从哪来的？那是怎么回事？我就像1883年就是这么来的。我知道。但是约翰，难道不是因为有个跟我身高差不多的娃娃吗？
Oh no, you were the identical replica of kid sister. And they had, it was a kid, was it big brother? No. No. Something. I would go. You, I would yell around. No, there was a boy one.
哦不，你简直就是妹妹的真人复刻版。他们有，那是一个小孩，是大哥哥吗？不是。不是。某种东西。我会去。你，我会大声喊。不，有一个男的。
And then they came out with a girl one that looked exactly like you. And I was at a store one day and saw it on a toy store like shell. And I took a photo of myself standing next to it. And I sent it to you. You were like, Oh my God. Oh, I remember that. Yes. But also you're the exact size of it compared to me, especially you're like perfect.
然后他们推出了一个长得跟你一模一样的女版。有一天我在一家店里，在玩具店的书架上看到了它。我拍了一张自己站在它旁边。我把它发给你了。你当时说，天哪。哦，我记得那个。是的。而且跟我和你相比，你刚好就是它那个尺寸，尤其是你简直完美。
And I remember one day, didn't you do like the stiff arms and stuff? And I like picked you up and you were like, yeah, it was great. It was good times. Someone, a fan wrote in and said, if you ever came on, could you and I do the bit? And I was like, well, it's a pretty kid sister, big brother. Oh, there it is. What jokes did we have? We didn't get along well.
我还记得有一天，你不是还做了那种僵硬的胳膊之类的动作吗？然后我把你抱起来，你就说，太棒了。那是段好时光。有人，一个粉丝写信来说，如果你将来上节目，你俩能表演那个小节目吗？我就想，嗯，这挺像妹妹和大哥哥的。哦，这不就来了。我们有什么笑话来着？我们以前相处得不太好。
What? What was it for us? Oh boy. What were our bits? What were our bits? Did we have so many bits? You know what? I remember bits wise was many different, um, inside jokes of like writing on post-it notes
什么？对我们来说那是什么？哦天哪。我们的搞笑桥段是什么？我们的搞笑桥段是什么？我们有那么多搞笑桥段吗？你知道吗？我记得的搞笑桥段就是各种不同的，呃，内部笑话，比如在便利贴上写字
and like all my memos that I had to hand to you for corporate always had selling written on them and John, you played one prank on me and the whole nine years of the author was like one like really fully formed, good, thought out prank. It was at Shroot Farms and you and I had this scene where we had to drive up to the farmhouse several times and we're doing it and I am getting increasingly more hot. I'm like warm. I'm sweating. I'm like, oh my God.
就像我所有要交给你代表公司公事的便签上都写着“出售”，而且约翰，你在《办公室》的九年里只对我搞了一次恶作剧，那是一个非常完整、很棒、深思熟虑的恶作剧。那是在施鲁特农场，你和我有一场戏，我们得把车开到农舍好几次，我们正在拍，然后我变得越来越热。我觉得很暖和。我在出汗。我想，天哪。
It was a hot day. It was so hot. And we had to turn off the AC for sound and you were like, yeah, I don't know. I'm okay, but you're hot, huh? And I'm like, I'm so hot. This went on for like 15 minutes and then all of a sudden you start snickering and you had turned on my seat warmer all the way to the hottest setting. Oh my God.
那是个大热天。天气太热了。为了收音，我们不得不关掉空调，然后你就说，是的，我不知道。我挺好的，但你很热，对吧？然后我说，我太热了。这种情况持续了大约15分钟，然后你突然吃吃地笑起来，原来你把我的座椅加热器开到了最高档。天哪。
That was late in the run, wasn't it? That was late in the run and I, but I was so excited because whenever we would go on talk shows, they would always ask us if we played pranks on each other and I would always say no. And I mean, not really. I mean, besides just like little jokes on post-it notes or something, not really, not really. I'm terrible at pranks.
那是拍到后期了吧？那是拍到后期了，而且我当时超级兴奋，因为每当我们在脱口秀节目上做客时，他们总是问我们是否互相恶作剧，我总是说没有。我的意思是，其实没有。我是说，除了在便利贴上写点小笑话什么的，真的没有，真的没有。我很不擅长搞恶作剧。
We weren't pranky, you know? But then finally after you did that in the car, I was like, oh my gosh, this is great. I can finally have a prank to talk about. Are you sad about that prank? What's sad about that prank? I realized that I'm such a bad prankster that I stole that prank from Clooney when we were doing Leatherheads. He did that to me.
我们不怎么搞恶作剧，你知道的？但后来你在车里做了那件事之后，我就想，哦天哪，这太棒了。我终于有一个可以拿来聊聊的恶作剧了。你为那个恶作剧感到难过吗？那个恶作剧有什么好难过的？我意识到自己是个如此糟糕的恶作剧者，我这个恶作剧是从我们在拍《皮面截击手》时学乔治·克鲁尼的。他对我也这么干过。
So that's how unoriginal I am. I was like, I'm going to take George Clooney's back and do it to Jenna and I thought that would make me cool. I got a recycled prank. You got Clooney is what you got. I did. One degree of separation. I think that prank just keeps getting cooler, like that's a pretty fancy prank.
所以我是多么没有原创性啊。我想：我要照搬乔治·克鲁尼的招数用在珍娜身上，我以为这会让我显得很酷。我得了一个二手恶作剧。你得到的是克鲁尼。我确实是。六度分隔理论。我觉得那个恶作剧变得越来越酷了，就像那是一个相当高级的恶作剧。
I think so too. That's a good prank. Let's get into the meat of your interview here, John. I thought we were doing pretty good. We were, but we should intro you a little. John, thank you so much for coming on the show. We always like to ask our guests a little bit about how they came to be on the office. And I know you've told this story like a million times, but is it true that you were originally
我也这么觉得。那是、个好恶作剧。我们来谈谈你这次采访的干货吧，约翰。我觉得我们表现得挺好的。我们确实挺好，不过我们应该先给你做个简短的介绍。约翰，非常感谢你来参加我们的节目。我们总是喜欢问我们的嘉宾一些关于他们是如何加入《办公室》的经历。我知道你这个故事已经讲过一百万遍了，但这是真的吗，你最初被
asked to audition for Dwight? Yes, I was. And that reminds me that about six seasons into the show, someone was like, I love how you say Dwight. And I was like, how do you say it? And they were like Dwight. And I was like, I know Dwight. And they were like, nope.
邀请去试镜德怀特（Dwight）？是的，我是。这让我想起大约在剧集拍到第六季时，有人说，我喜欢你发“Dwight”这个音的方式。我说，你是怎么发音的？他们说，Dwight。我说，我就是这么发音的。他们说，不对。
Dwight. And I was like, no, no, I'm saying it right. Dwight. And they were like, nope. It's not. So yes, I auditioned or no, I was offered to come in and audition for the role of Dwight. And I was so excited. I had met Alison Jones randomly out in LA on a general meeting when I had zero dollars
Dwight。我说，不，不，我发对了。Dwight。他们说，不对。不是这样的。所以是的，我试镜了，或者说不，我是被邀请去为德怀特这个角色试镜的。我当时太兴奋了。我在洛杉矶的一次全体会议上偶然遇到了艾莉森·琼斯，当时我身上只有
to my name. And she said, something's coming on our first meeting, our only meeting. She said, something's coming. Call the office. You'd be great for it. I said, great. So then I got back to New York and they said, there's this show called The Office. And I was like, oh my God, Alison Jones, the greatest human ever told me about this.
零美元。她说，有事情要发生了，这是我们的第一次会议，也是唯一一次会议。她说，有事情要发生了。给办公室打电话。你非常适合。我说，太好了。然后我回到纽约，他们说，有个节目叫《办公室》。我就想，天哪，史上最伟大的人艾莉森·琼斯跟我提过这个。
And they said, you're going in for the role of Dwight. And I had been a huge fan of the British show. And I was like, I don't know, man, that's not, I don't know if I'm right for that role. And so I weirdly have no idea what I was thinking. I said, you know what, I read the pilot and I said, you know what, I'm going to put my best foot forward. Let me know when they're casting gyms. And I remember the response from the NBC casting director to my manager at the time was, no,
他们说，你是去试镜德怀特这个角色的。我一直是这部英国剧集的超级粉丝，当时我就想，我不知道，伙计，那不是，我不知道我是否适合那个角色。所以奇怪的是，我不知道当时脑子里在想什么。我说，你知道吗，我读了试播集后说，你知道吗，我要拿出我最好的状态。等他们选吉姆的时候告诉我一声。我记得当时NBC的选秀导演对我当时的经纪人的回应是，不，
but honestly, who does he think he is? Like passing up an audition, an opportunity to audition. And lo and behold, I thought it was over and I think it was like five, six weeks later that they called and they were like, all right, they're looking for gyms now and they'll have you back. Oh my gosh. And that's so crazy. And then when we finally did our screen test, you, you were living in New York and you had
但说实话，他以为他是谁啊？竟然放弃试镜，放弃试镜的机会。结果没想到，我以为一切都结束了，大概过了五六周吧，他们打电话来说，好吧，他们现在在找演吉姆的人，想让你回来。哦天哪。这太疯狂了。然后当我们终于进行银幕测试时，你，你住在纽约，你当时
to fly to LA for that screen test. With all these New Yorkers that were auditioning, which was so much fun. I remember I took the plane with Jim Gaffigan, who was auditioning for a role. And it was like laughing, I mean, just was surrounded by heroes on the plane and then got to, got to the callback or the test or whatever they called it. And because I'm so, so experienced now, I have no idea what I'm talking about. But I remember getting in this big room and it was the waiting room of where we actually shot our pilot.
飞去洛杉矶参加那场试镜。当时有那么多纽约演员在试镜，真的非常有意思。我记得我是和吉姆·加菲根一起坐飞机去的，他也在试镜一个角色。当时大家一直在笑，我是说，飞机上周围全都是我心目中的大咖，然后去到了复试还是试镜，或者他们管那叫什么。因为我现在经验太丰富了，我完全不知道自己在说什么。但我记得我走进那个大房间，那正是我们实际拍摄试播集时的候诊室。
I'm sure you guys have covered that, but like where we shot our pilot is what they measured down to the quarter inch or centimeter to make our set, this building that existed. We took an existing building. And I remember sitting basically where like Ryan's desk, no, like where Mindy's desk was like Toby and Mindy's desk was, I was sitting against that wall and I saw all these other people coming in. I had been there for like an hour or two hours and all the other people were the LA people and I realized they had separated us.
我确信你们大家肯定聊过这个，但就像我们拍试播集的地方，他们把这里精确测量到四分之一英寸或厘米来搭建我们的布景，这座现有的建筑。我们用了一栋现有的建筑。我还记得我基本上坐在莱恩的办公桌那个位置，不，就像明迪的办公桌在的那里，托比和明迪的办公桌就在那，我靠着那面墙坐着，然后我看到其他所有人都走了进来。我在那儿待了一个小时还是两个小时，其他所有人都是洛杉矶本地人，然后我意识到他们把我们分开了。
And so they were asking the New York people to leave after they were done and then I was the last New York person and I saw all these LA people in and I started to get super self conscious. I am, I am not a confident person and I was like, oh my God, this is so embarrassing. I'm the only New Yorker here. Cause everybody was like, hey, Johnny Tim, like greeting each other and I was sitting on a floor like, so I went on to the set cause all the producers were hiding in the background. And I said, I'm so sorry.
所以他们让纽约的演员在结束后离开，然后我是最后一个离开的纽约演员，我看到所有这些洛杉矶演员进来，我开始变得超级不自在。我这人，我不是个自信的人，我就想，天哪，这太尴尬了。我是这里唯一的纽约人。因为每个人都在打招呼，嗨，强尼，蒂姆，互相问候，而我坐在地板上，于是我走上了布景，因为所有制片人都躲在背景里。我说，真的非常抱歉。
I think someone forgot to tell me to go home and from behind a like fake wall. I remember hearing like a lot of chair moving and stuff and like banging against the wall and it was Greg trying to get out of his chair and find the entrance to get back on set. And he was like, no, hold on one second, hold on one second, please hold on one second. And I heard Terry Weinberg being like, no, no, no, no, no, don't, don't go. And then I went back out to the waiting room, super freaked out and I saw Jenna walk in the door and she was like, as soon as I saw you walk in, Jen, I know I told the story at building time.
我想可能有人忘了叫我回家。然后我听到一个假墙后面，我记得听到很多椅子挪动的声音之类的，还有撞墙的声音，那是格雷格正试图从椅子里挣扎出来，找入口回到布景上。他说，不，等一下，等一下，请等一下。我听到特里·温伯格在说，不，不，不，不，别，别走。然后我又回到了候诊室，吓得要死，我看到珍娜走进门，她就像——詹，我一看到你走进来，我知道我在读剧本时说过这个故事。
So people are like, we get it. We've seen behind the scenes. I, I genuinely had like a metaphysical event where I was like, oh, that's who's in the show. That person will be in the show. And so they held me back. You went in with a bunch of people and I remember thinking, if I don't go in with her, I'm screwed. And that's when I went on the thing and said, you should let me go.
所以大家可能会觉得，我们懂了。我们看过幕后花絮了。我，我真的经历了一次类似灵魂出窍的事件，当时我想，哦，原来这就是剧里的人。这个人会出现在剧里。所以他们把我留下了。你和一群人一起走了进去，我当时心想，如果我不跟她一起进去，我就完蛋了。然后我走过去说，你们应该让我进去。
And they said, no, no, no, there's one more person we want you audition with and it was you. And I thought, oh my God, you're saying there's a chance because if I'm in with you, I knew I had a shot. Oh my God, John, I can go back to that moment that I saw you at the audition and I had that exact same reaction. I, it was, I've tried to describe it to people like what it was like to audition with you. And the best, like the best explanation I could come up with was like, what if you walked
他们说，不，不，不，还有一个我们想让你一起试镜的人，那就是你。然后我想，天哪，你是说还有机会，因为如果我和你一起试镜，我知道我有胜算。天哪，约翰，我又回到了在试镜时看到你的那一刻，我当时也有完全相同的反应。我，这经历过，我曾试图向别人描述和你一起试镜是什么感觉。而最好的，我能想到的最好解释就像是，如果你走进
into a room and music started playing and you and another person just started dancing in unison, even though you'd never met. That's what it was like auditioning with you. Wow, that's really way more beautiful than what I would say, which is like, I felt like I could see the future. I was like, it actually gave me anxiety because I was like, she's so on the show. It's so weird that I'm like watching a piece get in. And I remember, I'm sure you remember too, but when after our audition and I loved auditioning
一个房间，音乐开始响起，你和另一个人就开始齐声跳起舞来，尽管你们素未谋面。这就是和你一起试镜的感觉。哇，这真的比我要说的美妙多了，我想说的是，我觉得我能看到未来。我当时就想，这甚至让我感到焦虑，因为我想，她绝对会在剧里。我竟然在看一个演员入选，这太诡异了。而且我记得，我确信你也记得，在我们试镜结束后，我很喜欢和你
with you, we were walking through the kitchen and I said, because that was the way out. And I said, I just got to let you know, I think that you're going to get this part of your perfect for this. And you seem to remember, you said the same thing to me, I don't, because I blacked out. I was trying to not look you in the eyes. I was so excited that you said that because I felt like I had wanted to say that to you, but I didn't have the courage because I didn't know you. You were like, essentially a stranger to me.
一起试镜，我们穿过厨房，我说，因为那是出口。我说，我只想让你知道，我觉得你会得到这个角色，你太适合了。而你好像也记得，你对我也说了同样的话，我不记得了，因为我当时大脑一片空白。我努力不和你对视。我太高兴你能这么说了，因为我觉得我一直想对你这么说，但我没有勇气，因为我不认识你。你对我来说基本上是个陌生人。
The only time we had really spoken or interacted was during our audition. So we were kind of silently walking back to the kitchen and I was thinking in my head, should I tell him I think he's the best gym? Is that appropriate? Should I say you're the best gym? You're going to be gym or is that, is that bad form? I don't know. What's the etiquette?
我们真正说过话或互动过的唯一时间就是在试镜期间。所以我们有点默默无闻地走回厨房，我心里在想，我应该告诉他我觉得他是最棒的吉姆吗？这合适吗？我应该说你是最棒的吉姆吗？你要成为吉姆了，还是说，这表现很糟糕？我不知道。有什么礼仪吗？
And so when you said, I think you're going to get the role of Pam, my memory is that I was like, oh my God, I think you're going to be Jim, you're the best, you're my favorite gym, I was having a nosebleed at that time, don't remember much, but I do remember this though that I always say this and people are like, yeah, whatever, but it's true. I have a lottery ticket life ever since I was given the news that I was on that show. Everything changed in my life from every single way, not to get into a heady version, but not only every opportunity that I've ever had is from the show, I met my wife because she knew who I was in a restaurant for a show, we never would have been in the same city
所以当你开口说，我觉得你会得到帕姆这个角色时，我的记忆是，我当时在想，天哪，我觉得你会成为吉姆，你是最棒的，你是我最喜欢的吉姆，我当时在流鼻血，记不太清了，但我确实记得这件事，我总是这么说，人们可能会说，行吧，随便，但这是真的。自从我得到消息说我将出演那部剧起，我就过上了买彩票般的生活。我生活中的一切在方方面面都改变了，我不是想说得太玄乎，但这不仅是因为我得到的每一个机会都源于此，我还遇到了我的妻子，因为她在一家餐馆里认出了我是谁，我们俩原本绝不可能在同一个城市
or restaurant or anything. It's just so crazy how deep and crazy it goes, but I remember at the epicenter of it all, when I was told that I had the part, I actually jumped on a couch and then again, this metaphysical thing came over me where I went, wait, wait, wait, one second, did Jenna Fisher get the part of Pam? And they were like, we don't know, we just told you your life changed, are you happy enough with that? And I was like, no, you need to call them back and ask if Jenna got the part. Because I thought if you were on it, then I was going to be on one of the best things
或餐馆或任何地方相遇。这真的是深不可测又疯狂至极，但我记得在这一切的最中心，当我被告知我得到了这个角色时，我实际上兴奋得跳上了一张沙发，接着，又来了，这种玄之又玄的感觉向我袭来，我说，等等，等等，等一下，珍娜·费舍尔拿到帕姆的角色了吗？他们说，我们不知道，我们刚通知你你的人生改变了，你难道还不够高兴吗？我说，不，你们得给她回电话，问问珍娜拿没拿到角色。因为我想如果你也参演的话，那我就是在参与我这辈子做过的最棒的事情之一。
that I'll ever do in my life. And if they were like, no, you know, Rhonda, something would ever got it. And I'd be like, no, not Rhonda. Well, when they called me and told me that I got the part, I had a very similar reaction. And the first question I asked was, did John Krasinski get the role of Jim? Because I just felt like, I don't know if I can do Pam without you as Jim. So I was like, I need to know, did my partner in crime get this part? And they were like, yes, he did.
如果他们说，不，你知道的，隆达，随便什么人得到了。我会说，不，不要隆达。好吧，当他们打电话告诉我我得到了这个角色时，我的反应非常相似。我问的第一个问题是，约翰·卡拉辛斯基拿到吉姆的角色了吗？因为我当时觉得，我不知道如果没有你演吉姆，我能不能演好帕姆。所以我当时就想，我必须知道，我的犯罪同伙拿到这个角色了吗？他们说，是的，他拿到了。
And what's weird is that that's the first question he asked after he was told. And by the way, we never saw each other after the kitchen. I left. No, we didn't have each other's phone numbers. We couldn't text each other or email. So it was like, then I just waited until the pilot table read when we were all reunited. Same with Rain. I only met Rain at the audition.
奇怪的是，这也是他在被告知消息后问的第一个问题。顺便说一句，我们在厨房分开后再也没见过面。没有，我们没有彼此的电话号码。我们不能发短信或发电子邮件。所以就变成了，然后我一直在等试播集剧本围读，那时我们才终于重聚。雷恩也是。我只在试镜时见过雷恩。
And when I heard he got the role, I was like, well, that tracks because he was definitely the weirdest dude. Oh my God. I remember thinking, I remember doing this audition with Rain where Greg asked me to ask him to cover my phones. And of course, he said to Rain, under no circumstances, will you cover his phones? And I remember being like, hey, Dwight, will you just cover my phone? I just got to go to the bathroom.
当我听说他得到了这个角色时，我想，嗯，这很符合他的作风，因为他绝对是最古怪的家伙。天哪。我记得当时在想，我记得和雷恩做过那场试镜，当时格雷格让我叫他帮我接电话。当然，他对雷恩说，无论在什么情况下，你都不准接他的电话。我记得我当时说，嘿，德怀特，你能帮我接一下电话吗？我得去趟洗手间。
And he was like, sorry. And then pretended to close barn doors. And then I asked him again. And he did like shipping container doors. And I kept doing it. And by the end of it, not to Dwight, to the actor Rain, I was like, you are infuriating. You're an infuriating human. And I was like, he's going to get it.
他说，抱歉。然后假装关上谷仓的大门。然后我又问了他一遍。他又做了个集装箱大门的动作。我一直这么做。到最后，不是对德怀特，是对演员雷恩，我说，你太气人了。你是一个极其气人的人。然后我想，他肯定能入选。
Well, oh my gosh, I love all of that. All of that just makes my heart happy, you guys, hearing all of that. I don't know that I've, you know, I've heard snippets of those stories, but I've never heard all of it and watched you guys tell it is actually really beautiful. Just go and say. No, that's what I was going to say. I've actually never told those stories with you in, I was going to say in person or not. In digital form.
天哪，我太喜欢这些了。所有这些都让我的内心感到快乐，伙计们，听到这一切。我不知道我是否——你知道的，我听过这些故事的片段，但我从未听过完整版，看着你们讲述这些其实真的很美妙。只想说。不，这就是我要说的。实际上，我从来没有和你们一起讲过这些故事，不管是当面还是——我要说的是，通过数码形式。
Same. I feel like we've told those stories separately on talk shows or interviews, but actually never to one another. Yeah, it's like, there's always these things where you're like, is that what happened? It's so interesting. So amazing. I have so many stories that I'm like, I wonder if people know that it's like some of my favorite stuff is like, sort of, I guess it's a secret, but I don't know, oh, like one of my favorite
我也是。我觉得我们之前在脱口秀或采访中分别讲过这些故事，但从没对彼此讲过。对啊，就好像，总会有这种时候，你会想，事情真的是那样发生的吗？太有趣了。太棒了。我有好多故事，常常心想，不知道大家知不知道这些，这就像是我最喜欢的一些东西，算是个秘密吧，但我不知道，哦，比如我最喜欢的其中一个故事。
stories. I ever tell you this story was when we wrapped, by the way, how dare Greg Daniels do that rap. Remember that when he was like, yeah, I just got to get you guys leaving the office a couple of times for, I got to cut it into the earlier part of the show and we were all just totally goofing off and laughing, heading to like for Richard's line. And then when we came back, he was standing there all weird. Remember that?
我跟你讲过这个故事吗？就是当我们杀青的时候，顺便问一句，格雷格·丹尼尔斯怎么敢搞那个杀青恶作剧？还记得吗，当时他说，好吧，我只需要让你们离开办公室好几次，因为，我得把它剪到剧集的前面部分去，当时我们都在完全胡闹大笑，朝着理查德的台词方向走去。然后当我们回来时，他站在那里怪里怪气的。记得吗？
Yeah. And it was like, that was the last take of anything like, ladies and gentlemen, I just want to tell you that the show has concluded or the office is over and that's a wrap. That's a wrap. And I was like, and I definitely threw up on my shoes. Someone took a picture of that moment. I don't know who it was, but what all give me that picture. We're disintegrating.
记得。这就好像是任何事情的最后一条拍摄——女士们先生们，我只想告诉大家，这部剧已经杀青了，或者说办公室结束了，这就是杀青。大功告成。然后我想，我绝对吐在鞋上了。有人拍下了那一刻的照片。我不知道是谁，但不管是谁把那张照片给我。我们在瓦解。
Yeah. We're like all of us. But he did. It was like some weird, incredibly smart move to like just because we all knew it was coming and then he did the smartest thing by being like, oh, shoot, I got to do this one more thing. Like just get out of the office, walk a couple of times. I just need you to exit.
对。我们就像所有人一样。但他真的这么做了。这真是一个奇怪、聪明绝顶的举动，因为我们都知道它要来了，然后他做出了最聪明的举动，装作，哦，糟糕，我得再拍这最后一场戏。就像，离开办公室，走几次。我只需要你们走出去。
And I remember Randall being weird, so he must have been in on it. And then when Greg came out, I remember we looked in all the crew, everyone that had been in Video Village had come out on the stage. They were all sort of like, yeah, and I was just like, what's happening? We all ended like together, like, it was so intense. It was like, I'm your dad and I'm leaving you and you're like, what? Um, but the funny thing was that day, everybody was really emotional and we had the rap party and so everybody was like trying to get themselves together.
我记得雷恩表现得很奇怪，所以他肯定知情。然后当格雷格出来时，我记得我们看着，所有的剧组人员，所有在视频监视区的人都来到了舞台上。他们都在那儿欢呼，而我只是在想，发生了什么？我们最后都在一起了，那种感觉，太强烈了。就像是，我是你爸爸，我要离开你了，而你的反应是，什么？嗯，但有趣的是那天，每个人都很情绪化，我们举行了杀青派对，所以每个人都在努力克制自己。
And I think of myself as a somewhat moral person and I had the weirdest idea when I got back to the trailer, I was crying like crazy and I went, oh my God, there's one thing I want. It's like, like, what's the one thing you would want from the show? And I ran back and stole the Dunder Mifflin sign that we all did talking heads to. I remember that. And then I think I did tell you, Jenna, because I was like, so Catholic, I was like, most tell someone and then we got to the party and I'll never forgive myself.
我觉得自己算是一个比较有道德的人，当我回到保姆车时，我脑子里冒出了一个最奇怪的想法，我当时哭得死去活来，然后我想，天哪，我只有这一个愿望。这就好像，从剧里你最想要什么东西？我跑回去，偷走了那块我们所有人都在面对镜头说访谈画外音的邓德米夫林标牌。我记得那个。然后我想我确实告诉你了，珍娜，因为我内心极其罪恶，我觉得，我必须告诉某个人，然后我们到了派对上，我永远不会原谅自己。
I don't even know if he knows that we're at the party and I saw Greg and I was like, Greg, thank you for my whole life and like whatever. And he was like, yeah, yeah, no problem. And I was like, how are you doing? He goes, ah, good, you know, I'm a little bummed. The one thing I wanted was the Dunder Mifflin sign, he goes, but someone took it and literally my brain exploded and I went, that sucks, man, whoever did that, that sucks. I remember saying to him, I lied to my dad, I lied to my TV creator, I lied to his face.
我甚至不知道他知不知道我们在派对上，我看到格雷格，然后我说，格雷格，谢谢你给我的一生，诸如此类的话。他说，对，对，没问题。然后我说，你最近怎么样？他说，啊，挺好的，你知道的，我有点失落。我唯一想要的东西就是那个邓德米夫林标牌，他说，但是被人拿走了。字面意义上，我的大脑瞬间爆炸了，我说，太逊了吧，哥们，不管是谁干的，太逊了。我记得当时对他说，我对我爸撒了谎，我对我电视节目的创作者撒了谎，我当着他的面撒了谎。
I remember you loading out your trailer and I walked out and I have a visual of you putting it in your car. It was very large. It was very large. It was very large because I only had like a bath towel and that didn't even begin to cover it. It was just like, it was the worst heist of all time. And I also remember people being like, why is John leaving so fast?
我记得你把保姆车的东西搬出来，我走了出去，脑子里有你把它放进车里的画面。那个标牌很大。非常大。非常大，因为我只有一条浴巾，那根本遮不住它。这简直是史上最糟糕的盗窃案。我还记得当时有人在问，为什么约翰走得这么快？
And I was like, don't look at me. Like as I drove out of the parking lot, it was so weird. Do you remember the big sign that, well, it was like a fake painting of me looking angry that hung in the senator's house? Oh yeah. The art department gave that to me. That's amazing. It's enormous.
我说，别看我。当我把车开出停车场时，那感觉太诡异了。你还记得那个大招牌吗，呃，就是一幅挂在参议员家里的、我看起来很生气的假画？哦，对。美术部门把那个送给我了。太棒了。那个巨大无比。
It's the size of a small love seat sofa. If we're sharing secrets, I'll say that I asked if I could have Pam's watercolor of Dunder Mifflin. And I was told officially from production that I could not have it because it was going to be cataloged as part of like the set decoration and it would be stored at NBC and no, I couldn't have it. I was really heartbroken because besides a couple of trinkets on my desk and like a few pieces of wardrobe, I really hadn't saved anything else.
它有一个小型双人沙发那么大。如果我们要在分享秘密的话，我要说的是，我曾问过我能不能要帕姆画的那幅邓德米夫林的水彩画。制作组官方答复我说我不能拿走它，因为这将被编目为布景装饰的一部分，并会存放在NBC，不行，我不能要。我当时真的心碎了，因为除了我桌上的几个小玩意儿和几件戏服外，我真的没有保存任何别的东西。
That was really the one thing I wanted. And oh my gosh, I'm going to cry a little bit. As I was leaving, Phil Shea ran up to me and he said, here, you should have this. I made a color photo of it. They'll never know. No way. I have the original in my house. You owe me.
那真的是我唯一想要的东西。天哪，我快要哭了。就在我要离开的时候，菲尔·谢伊跑向我说，给你，你应该拿着这个。我做了一张它的彩色照片。他们永远不会发现。不会吧。我家里有原作。你欠我的。
Oh my God. That's amazing. Dude, Phil Shea is the reason I have anything. He sent me a box like years, like three or four years later of my bag, my nameplate. Your satchel that you would use. Yeah, my satchel, my nameplate and the teapot, bro. You have the teapot. You have the teapot.
天哪。太棒了。老兄，菲尔·谢伊就是我能拥有任何东西的原因。几年后，大概三四年后，他给我寄了一个箱子，里面有我的包，我的名牌。你平时用的那个斜挎包。对，我的斜挎包，我的名牌，还有那个茶壶，兄弟。你有那个茶壶。你有那个茶壶。
We have the teapot. We have the teapot. We have been wondering you had the teapot. Teapot, son. Son of a gun. Wow. You have it. Oh man, I thought you knew that.
我们有那个茶壶。我们有那个茶壶。我们一直想知道是谁拿走了茶壶。茶壶，我的好兄弟。真有你的。哇。你有它。哦，天哪，我还以为你知道呢。
No, no. I didn't know it was a great caper. Shea said, I have always wondered who got the teapot. Who got that teapot? I've always wondered. You know what's so funny is I had the greatest idea because I heard your amazing podcast about the teapot episode and I was going to take a picture of it in my room and totally forgot.
不，不。我不知道这是一场惊天大盗。谢伊说，我一直想知道是谁拿走了茶壶。谁拿了那个茶壶？我一直很好奇。你知道最搞笑的是什么吗，我当时有个绝妙的主意，因为我听了你们关于茶壶那一集的精彩播客，我本打算在我的房间里拍张它的照片，结果完全给忘到脑后了。
I wanted to like post it right after I had heard your episode. Oh my gosh, that would have blown my mind. Yeah. I'm sure there's a couple because in case anyone broke, you could probably get one, I'm sure. I know. But you have the teapot. That's huge.
我本来想在听完你们那一集后立刻发出来的。天哪，那一定会把我震撼到。对啊。我确信肯定还有几个，因为万一有人弄坏了，你大概还能弄到一个，我敢肯定。我懂的。但你竟然有茶壶。这太牛了。
So there you go. So John, we are currently on the scene outside in the parking lot where Roy just took off in his truck and said, told me to keep an eye on you. Remember that? Yeah. Jenna's dressed as a bridesmaid. Jenna looks like a bridesmaid. I remember talking to Jenna about this a couple of times about like how Jenna's take
所以你看。所以，约翰，我们现在正处于外面停车场的场景，罗伊刚刚开着卡车离开，并且说，让我盯紧你。还记得吗？记得。珍娜穿着伴娘礼服。珍娜看起来像个伴娘。我记得和珍娜讨论过好几次这个场景，关于珍娜对这场戏的
on it was like, or for Pam's take, whatever she was like, little saucy of Jim to be like, you got it. Like a little devious right from the beginning, like this nice guy was like, oh, you bet. I'll take care of her. Oh, I'll take care of her. No, I remember that that that moment in particular was insane for so many reasons because I remember how, again, I keep talking about this like metaphysical thing, but I remember that like the cells of my body were really buzzing because I saw the crew like running around and deciding
理解，或者说对帕姆的理解，无论是怎样的，她觉得吉姆说出“你懂的”时有点厚脸皮。从一开始就有点狡猾，这个好人就像是，哦，包在我身上。哦，我会照顾好她的。不，我记得那一刻特别疯狂，原因有很多，因为我记得那种，再次强调，我一直在谈论这种类似灵魂出头的玄学现象，但我记得我身体里的细胞真的在沸腾，因为我看到剧组人员在四处奔跑，决定把摄像机藏在哪里
where to hide the cameras and Ken Quapas was our director and was phenomenal and making it feel like it's no big deal. We're just doing a scene of a show that'll never be seen. And then you're like, I think that's going to be more than that. And he was like, who cares? Just do it. Like he was trying to like keep it so low. And I remember you and I were in like a stairwell or something waiting.
肯·夸帕斯是我们的导演，他表现得太出色了，让一切看起来没什么大不了的。我们只是在排演一集永远不会播出的剧集中的一个场景。然后你就会想，我觉得这绝不止于此。而他却说，谁在乎呢？演就是了。他当时试图把事情处理得极其低调。我还记得你和我当时在某个楼梯间或什么地方等着。
Yeah. And everybody was deciding, do you do the cameras? Can they see the cameras? Can they not see the cameras, meaning Jim and Pam, can they see the cameras, whatever? Are they aware of the documentary crew? And I remember, I think it was Ken, right, who just said, I think I'm going to make the decision that they don't. And I remember Matt, I think, I think I remember this again, I'm elderly, but I, I feel like,
对。每个人都在纠结，要不要用摄像机？他们能看到摄像机吗？他们看不到摄像机吗，我是指吉姆和帕姆，他们能看到摄像机吗，诸如此类？他们意识到纪录片剧组的存在吗？我记得，好像是肯，对吧，他只是说，我觉得我决定让他们看不到。我记得，马特，我想，我觉得我又记得了，虽然我老了，但我，我觉得，
I feel like Ken placed the cameras and didn't tell us exactly where they were going to be. Yeah. That sounds like Ken. Well, there was this big argument that went back to even when the script came out, which was, should we film this scene with video or with audio only? Like this idea. Oh, right, right, right, yes. And I think the reason we were in a stairwell for a very long time, John, was because they
我觉得肯把摄像机安置好了，但没有确切告诉我们它们会放在哪里。听起来很像肯的作风。好吧，当时有一场激烈的争论，甚至可以追溯到剧本刚出来的时候，那就是：我们应该用视频还是纯音频来拍摄这场戏？有这种想法。哦，对，对，对，是的。我想我们在楼梯间待了很长时间的原因，约翰，是因为他们在
were deciding if we should have walked inside and gone onto the stairwell and we said the lines and right when we got to the end of the scene, the camera would find us and we would be looking at each other in silence. Yes. The idea was that Randall would be running to try to get it on film. Yes. And that was kind of like Greg wanted that and like half the writers wanted that. Yeah.
决定我们是否应该走进去，走到楼梯间里，我们说完台词，就在我们走到场景尽头的那一刻，摄像机会找到我们，然后我们会默默地看着彼此。对。当时的构思是雷恩会跑过来试图把它拍进电影里。对。这有点像是格雷格想要的，一半的编剧也想要那样。对。
Imagine how good the show could have been if that was the case. I know. But instead, but then and on, by the way, on Wikipedia, it claims that we shot that footage and it has never been seen, but that's not true. We never shot that. We only rehearsed it. I don't remember ever shooting a version. Do you?
想象一下，如果真是那样，这部剧会有多好。我懂的。但相反，而且，顺便说一句，维基百科上声称我们拍了那个素材而且从未曝光过，但那不是真的。我们从来没拍过那个。我们只排练过。我不记得拍过任何版本。你呢？
Yeah. I thought we rehearsed it. And then I thought, what I do remember maybe vaguely is that Ken was like, and if we do that version, we'll have the audio, so don't worry about it. Remember like, I remember Ken, I think was saying to Greg, like, listen, Greg, the good news is if we do end up going that route, we will already have the audio. Let's just shoot it out here first, and it was like a Jedi mind trick to get Greg to go with it.
对。我以为我们排练过。然后我想，我可能隐约记得的是，肯曾说过，如果我们拍那个版本，我们会录下音频，所以不用担心。记得吗，我记得肯当时好像在对格雷格说，听着，格雷格，好消息是如果我们最后真的走那条路，我们已经有音频了。我们先在这里拍这个，这就像是一个绝地精神把戏，为了让格雷格顺从。
Right. But I do remember that they did. Another reason we were in the stairwell was so that they were going to set the cameras outside. And when we came out, we wouldn't know where the cameras were. Right. And I remember feeling very alone in the parking lot. Well, again, because all the crew is like kind of buzzy about it and like, hello and
对。但我确实记得他们拍了。我们在楼梯间的另一个原因是为了把摄像机架在外面。当我们出来时，我们不会知道摄像机在哪里。对。我还记得在停车场里感到非常孤独。好吧，同样是因为所有的剧组人员都对这件事兴奋不已，打着招呼，而且
like, all our great friends that I would like be. I remember I was at the craft service table, not for this scene, but the next scene. And it's like, I remember going like, you know, hey, Chris, who we were like in fancy football, one of my favorite people, Chris Workman. And I was like, hey, Chris, and he was like, hello, John. And then like moved. And I was like, whoa, I don't think he's ever used the full word hello ever. That was the weirdest thing I've ever heard.
像我们所有好朋友，我都想。我记得当时我在演职人员餐车旁，不是为了这场戏，而是为了下一场戏。我记得当时在说，嘿，克里斯——我们在梦幻足球里，我最喜欢的人之一，克里斯·沃克曼。我说，嘿，克里斯。他说，你好，约翰。然后就走开了。我就想，哇，我觉得他这辈子从来没完整说过“你好”这两个字。这是我听过最诡异的事情。
Like everybody was so buzzed up about that. I don't remember this, Jenna. Do you have any semblance of an idea of how many takes of that we did? Because I remember genuinely being extremely nervous, which I was like, this will be great for the scene because I think it was probably, or at least I had probably interpreted it as the biggest scene I had done on the show or something to that level of, that level of intensity was like super terrifying to me. And I remember in my head being like, Hey, bro, remember when you thought you were an
好像每个人都对这件事兴奋过度了。我不记得这个了，珍娜。你对我们拍了多少条有哪怕一点点印象吗？因为我记得自己当时确实极其紧张，而我当时想，这对于这个场景来说太棒了，因为我想这可能是，或者至少我当时把它解读为我在剧里拍过的最大的一场戏，或者达到那种强度的场景对我来说简直太可怕了。我记得我脑子里在想，嘿，兄弟，还记得你觉得自己今晚是个演员吗，这场戏直接粉碎了那个幻觉，我当时太紧张了，无法完成那场戏，但今天再次看它时，
actor tonight ruins that whole mirage and I was so, I was so nervous to do that scene, but actually watching it again today. It was really amazing because we were like kind of standing close to each other and it was like, it was all very awkward and perfect. It was so good. I wrote in my journal, oh my God, John Krasinski, well, and that tear, oh my God, I have it. I'm just going to grab it, send it to you, John. Please.
真的太棒了，因为我们当时有点挨得很近，这感觉，非常尴尬但又完美。太棒了。我在日记里写道，天哪，约翰·卡拉辛斯基，还有那滴眼泪，天哪，我有写。我这就把它找出来，发给你，约翰。请务必发。
Oh my God. You wrecked us. You wrecked me. Oh, you were so good. Both of you guys were so good. I think I also remember Ken being such a good director was like, you know, so in this scene, how you feeling and, you know, how you feeling? And I was like, yeah, good.
天哪。你把我们击垮了。你把我击垮了。哦，你们俩演得太好了。你们两个都太棒了。我想我还记得肯作为一个出色的导演会说，你知道的，所以在这个场景里，你感觉怎么样，你知道的，你感觉怎么样？我说，嗯，挺好的。
I said, you know, I'm going to be really honest with you, Ken, this is a, this is a layup for me, bro, because I lived it and he was like, what do you mean? And I was like, dude, in my high school yearbook, I have every single girl in the school being like, thank you so much. You were the shoulder to cry on. You were such a good friend when I was in love with Adam, like all this stuff. I was like, no problem. So then when he was like, hey, do a scene about the love of your life, having another
我说，你知道的，我要跟你说实话，肯，这对我来说简直是小菜一碟，兄弟，因为我亲身经历过。他说，你什么意思？我说，老兄，在我的高中毕业纪念册里，学校里的每个女孩都对我说，非常感谢你。你是我可以依靠的肩膀。当我爱上亚当的时候，你是个那么好的朋友，诸如此类。我说，小菜一碟。所以当他说，嘿，演一个关于你此生挚爱却爱上
guy instead of you. And I was like, bro, it's called my default setting. Well, I, I remember shivering because I was freezing. It was really cold out and I was in that little dress and the desert night, the desert night we'll get you. Oh, it was chilly. And I also, so here, here was something that I, I traded some messages with Ken Quapas about this scene.
另一个而不是你的家伙的场景时。我说，老兄，这叫我的出厂设置。好吧，我当时在发抖，因为我冻坏了。外面真的太冷了，我穿着那条小裙子，沙漠的夜晚，沙漠的夜晚会让你吃不消的。哦，真的很冷。而且我还有，所以这里，这里有点东西，我和肯·夸帕斯就这个场景交换过一些信息。
And he reminded me that we had actually filmed the kiss the night before that, yeah, we filmed the kiss the day before and that this was the very final thing we shot for casino night. It took longer than any other scene. We spent more time on it than any other scene and we played around with the dialogue. So I have the script too. And what's in the script is a little different. And the thing is, is that that's my memory. I remember when I think back, the scene we were most nervous about was this scene and
他提醒我，我们在那之前的那天晚上其实就已经拍过那个吻了，是的，我们在前一天拍了那个吻，而这是我们为赌场之夜拍摄的最后一场戏。它比任何其他场景花的时间都长。我们在这场戏上花的时间比任何其他场景都多，并且我们对台词进行了调整。所以我也留着剧本。剧本里的内容其实有点不同。问题是，这就是我的记忆。当我回想时，我们最紧张的场景就是这场戏，
people always ask about the kiss, but this was the scene we worked hardest on. And it makes sense to me saying, I'm in love with you is such a vulnerable thing and you do it so honestly, John. And I also remember that those lines where I was saying like, Oh, do you want me to take your money now? Or I could take it later. Or when do that was all banter that we came up with on the spot that you were going to then like shock me out of.
人们总是问起那个吻，但这是我们下功夫最多的场景。对我来说这说得通，说出“我爱上你了”是如此脆弱的一件事，而你做得如此真诚，约翰。我还记得那些台词，我说，“哦，你是想现在拿走你的钱，还是等会儿再拿？或者什么时候拿？”所有这些都是我们当场即兴想出来的俏皮话，然后你会用这些话把我从情绪中惊醒。
And then I remember that stuff, that line where you said, when I'm like, I'm really sorry if you misinterpreted our friendship and you're like, don't. When you said, don't come on improv and I like my stomach, like my heart dropped into my stomach. I was like, Oh my God. I'm so sorry. That's what I love is like you're doing this as Pam and as Jenny, you're like, so sorry bro.
然后我还记得那些台词，当你对我说，当我表现得像“如果你误解了我们的友谊，我真的很抱歉”，而你却说，“别这样”。当你说了“别这样”并进行即兴发挥时，我的胃部一阵紧缩，我的心直接掉到了胃里。我当时想，天哪。我很抱歉。这就是我最喜欢的地方，你当时既是在演帕姆，也是在做珍娜，你就像是在说，真的很抱歉，兄弟。
That was really rude. I was like everything. Like I was having to be Pam, but on the inside, I was like, I was sorry because you were, you know, and you, you cried in a couple of the takes, I remember. But the one that they used, I think was the first time like, cause it was so, it wrecked me. It wrecked me. And I was like, my job is just stand here and stare at him.
这也太粗鲁了吧。我当时的感觉就是一切。就像我必须表现得像帕姆，但在内心深处，我在想，我真的很抱歉，因为你，你知道的，你在好几个镜头里都哭了，我记得。但他们最终采用的那条，我想那是第一次，因为，它太击垮我了。它彻底击垮了我。当时我想，我的工作就是站在那儿盯着他看。
And after they yelled cut, I feel like I was like, Oh my God, I'm terrible. There you are saying, telling us now that you were there being like, Oh my God, I'm so sorry. And watching it back today. I was like, Jesus. It was cold as ice like that was cold, but I also think Pam was just like, and listen, John, I always defend Jim like throughout our podcast, when anything happens, I'm like, Pam is horrible.
然后他们喊“卡”之后，我觉得我就像是在想，“天哪，我太糟糕了。”你在那里说，现在告诉我们你当时在那儿就像是，“天哪，真的非常抱歉。”今天回看的时候。我在想，天哪。真是冷酷得像冰一样，那真是太冷酷了，但我也觉得帕姆只是觉得，听着，约翰，在我们的播客中，我一直都在为吉姆辩护，每当发生什么事时，我就会想，帕姆太糟糕了。
Poor Jim. But in this moment, I really saw her as just totally completely was deer and headlights. Like everything was so real now. And once it's out there, it is out there, you know, and all of a sudden she's going to have to be accountable. Yes. I felt the same way watching it back. I was like, cause I remember it differently.
可怜的吉姆。但在那一刻，我真的觉得她整个人就像惊慌失措的小鹿。就像一切都变得那么真实，而一旦事情公之于众，那就真的是覆水难收了，你知道的，突然之间她必须承担责任。是的。我回看的时候也有同感。我想，因为我的记忆完全不同。
I remember like, there were like three more moments and casino night of us flirting. And then when, when my man turns around and is like, I want to tell you something, you're like, that's a fast. Like I even me was like, Hey man, that is bad game. Stop. You know what it though that the scene that I loved was, and I realized it didn't come out of the blue is cause of Jan and when she goes, did you tell anybody? And I was like, right, he has to tell her now cause he can never do it again.
我记得，在赌场之夜里，我们调情还有大概另外三个瞬间。然后当，当我的男神转过身来说，我有话要告诉你，你会想，这也太逊了。连我都觉得，嘿，老兄，这招太烂了。停下。你知道吗，我最喜欢的场景是，我意识到这并非空穴来风，全都是因为简，当她说，你告诉别人了吗？我就想，对啊，他现在必须告诉她，因为他再也不能这么做了。
That was, that was awesome. Such good writing. Who are those people? Yeah. Also, just like so kind. Like I feel like our, like Greg and Ken, like they were so gracious to let us have room to find those moments. You know, like they really like, right from the beginning, like we didn't need a lot of
太棒了，真的太棒了。写得太好了。那些人是谁？是的。而且，人也太好了。我觉得我们的，就像格雷格和肯，他们真的是太好了，给我们留出了空间去寻找那些时刻。你知道的，他们真的，从一开始，我们就根本不需要多少
room after that. Which is so, but for those moments, they were so respectful. So, which again leads to the second part, which is, sorry, I'm jumping on your end. No, no, no. I'll move us along, but I wanted to say one more thing, which was when I was watching it back, I was like, what does Pam think Roy is secretly taping her or something? Like she seemed like a spy who was like, I am very sorry, but I am loyal to Roy Anderson. I can't do this.
之后的那种空间。虽说如此，但对于那些时刻，他们是如此尊重。所以，这又引出了第二部分，也就是，抱歉，我打断你了。不，不，不。我来推动进度，但我还想说最后一件事，那就是当我回看的时候，我在想，帕姆到底觉得罗伊在暗中录音还是怎么着？她看起来就像是个特工，表现得像：非常抱歉，但我对罗伊·安德森忠心耿耿。我不能这么做。
You are a wonderful friend to me. But I obviously was impacting her because we're going to move into the bullpen and she goes up and calls her mom. To compliment your acting though, that, I mean, that has got to be, my favorite thing on any performance is when it's exactly what you imagine it would be, right? Cause in the movies and TV, you're like, we've been programmed as kids to say that when someone says I love you when you're sort of with someone else, you go, excuse me, how dare you in this whole dramatic thing, but instead your brain's just like, run the program, shut him down.
你对我来说是个绝佳的朋友。但这显然对她产生了影响，因为我们要搬到办公大厅去了，而她走过去给她妈妈打电话。不过为了赞美你的演技，那就是，我必须说，在任何表演中我最喜欢的一点就是，当它完全如你想象中的那样时，对吧？因为在电影和电视里，你会觉得，我们从小就被灌输了这样一种观念：当有人对你说“我爱你”，而你其实正和别人在一起时，你会说，不好意思，你怎么敢这样，然后是一整套戏剧化的反应，但相反，你的大脑只会发出这样的指令：执行程序，让他闭嘴。
Like there's no emotion. Mayday, mayday, escape. Exactly. Pull the cord, pull the cord. Should we talk about the big old kiss? It's not even a big kiss, it's a little kiss, but it's the perfect kiss. It was substantial. It's also my first kiss, first kiss I ever had acting.
就像没有任何情绪一样。五月天，五月天，快逃。没错。拔掉电源，拔掉电源。我们要聊聊那个大大的吻吗？它甚至算不上一个大吻，只是一个小吻，但它是完美的吻。它很有分量。这也是我的初吻，我演戏以来的第一个吻。
That was my first acting kiss ever. Mine was with Dwight. It was my second. Now that I say that, I'm wondering when else I would have had the opportunity, but like, no college play kissing, no nothing. That was nothing. Wow. That was your first on-screen kiss?
那是我有生以来第一个荧幕初吻。我的初吻是和德怀特。这是我的第二个。现在我这么一说，我在想我还能在什么时候有这种机会，不过，没有大学戏剧里的接吻，什么都没有。那根本不算什么。哇。那是你的荧幕初吻？
My first fake kiss. It was my second. I had done a movie called Born Champion, and I had a kiss scene in that. It was a sag low budget, I think maybe a non-union film. So I was, I was one kiss more experienced than John. Which is a lot. I was so nervous. And here's something that Ken Quapas reminded me, John.
我的假吻初吻。这是我的第二个。我曾拍过一部名为《天生赢家》的电影，我在里面有一场吻戏。那是一部萨格低成本电影，我想可能是一部非工会电影。所以，我比约翰多了一次接吻经验。这可真不少。我当时紧张极了。肯·夸帕斯提醒了我一件事，约翰。
He said, let me find it, it was so sweet. Ken said, I remember the day we did the kissing scene, you and John were off the charts nervous. And he said, he felt like it was his job to be really casual about the scene, to kind of undercut how momentous it was. And I remember that he was being super casual about it, but he said, but what didn't help was that on the shooting schedule, this scene description read, Jim kisses Pam in all caps, italics, and three exclamation points. This is what we train for people, you're like, okay, like, geez, calm down, that's what I
他说，让我想想，这太暖心了。肯说，我记得我们拍吻戏的那天，你和约翰紧张得无以复加。他说，他觉得他的职责就是对这场戏表现得非常随性，以此来冲淡这一刻的重大意义。我记得他当时对此表现得超级随性，但他接着说，不过无济于事的是，在拍摄日程表上，这场戏的描述写着：吉姆吻了帕姆，全是大写字母、斜体字，后面还有三个感叹号。这就是我们为之训练的成果，大家会觉得，好吧，天哪，冷静点，这就是我
went to. That's such a fun detail. And I think probably the crew was given the notice of like, guys, keep it cool, right? Let's not mess this up. Because that's when Chris Workman was like holding a, you know, a plate of like peanut butter pretzels or something was like, whoa, John. And then like walked away and I was like, Chris, what the hell was that? But I also remember you were in your trailer for a while and I thought you were upset because
经历的事。这个细节太有趣了。我想剧组可能也接到了通知，类似于，伙计们，保持冷静，对吧？别搞砸了。因为那时克里斯·沃克曼正拿着一盘，你知道的，花生酱蝴蝶结饼干之类的东西，然后说，哇，约翰。接着就走开了，当时我在想，克里斯，这到底是怎么回事？但我也记得你在化妆车里待了一会儿，我以为你很不高兴，因为
I was on, I was on stage all the time because I was usually around crafty. And and I had heard that you were in your trailer and I was like, is everything okay? And I didn't know what was happening. And then I remember again, similarly, they told me that they were ready. And when we, when I got on set, I was first on set at how I remember at least I was first on set and was looking for Randall and Matt because I used to goof around with those guys. And weirdly, my default setting is like, make jokes when you're nervous. So I was looking for them and I was genuinely crestfallen when I couldn't find them because
我一直在片场，因为我通常都在零食区附近。我听说你在化妆车里，我就想，一切都还好吧？我当时不知道发生了什么。然后我记得同样地，他们告诉我准备好了。当我来到片场时，据我记忆至少我是第一个到片场的，并且在找兰德尔和马特，因为我以前经常跟那几个家伙恶作剧。奇怪的是，我的本能反应就是：紧张的时候就讲笑话。所以我当时在找他们，当我找不到他们时，我是真的感到一阵沮丧，因为
then I was really nervous because I was like, oh my God, but if my, if my bit machine isn't going to work, then what do we do? And then they were like, John, so you're going to go to the front door and I was like front door? What the hell? And I got so, then I got so weirded out. And then someone came, I don't know if was it Jasmine was on yet? But I don't know.
那我可就真的紧张了，因为我在想，哦天哪，如果我的搞笑机器不管用了，那我们该怎么办？然后他们说，约翰，现在你要去前门那儿，我说前门？搞什么鬼？然后我变得好奇怪。接着有人走过来，我不知道，那时候贾斯敏来过了吗？但我不知道。
I think it was Jazz came up and was like, and I was like, I just remember like a person being like, and go and it was like, I was in slow motion. I was like, do what? And I just went on and it was so weird. Well, I remember rehearsing, I'm going to put that in quotes. I remember discussing the scene in the days prior. I had a bunch of meetings with Greg and you and Ken where we all talked about it, like how big should the kiss be?
我想是贾兹走过来，然后说，我只记得有个人说，开始吧，就像是我在慢动作中一样。我在想，做什么？然后我就上去了，这感觉太诡异了。好吧，我记得在排练，我要给这个词加上引号。我记得在之前的几天里讨论过这场戏。我和格雷格、你还有肯开过好几次会，我们一起讨论过，这个吻应该有多热烈？
I remember asking how much does Pam kiss him back? We discussed that she would definitely allow herself to be kissed. And then, but did she really like kissing back? How long should it go on? Like just sort of general chitty chatness about how it would play out. And then I remember on the day doing a very rough blocking of it, but alone. Like when you were like, what is she doing in her trailer? They had brought me to set to rehearse by myself.
我记得我问过帕姆回吻了多少？我们讨论过她绝对会允许自己被亲吻。然后，但她真的喜欢回吻吗？应该持续多久？就像是关于这场戏将如何展开的一些日常闲聊。然后我记得在当天对它进行了非常粗略的走位，但是是独自进行的。就像你当时在想，她在化妆车里干什么呢？他们带我去片场一个人排练。
This is where you're going to stand at Jim's desk. There was a big discussion. Why am I not standing at reception? It was because it would be too hard for you to get to me. They wanted to put the camera in the kitchen so that we couldn't see it. They would shoot it through the blinds. It would be super secret spy shot. And that was the best position.
这就是你要在吉姆办公桌旁站立的位置。当时有一场激烈的讨论。为什么我不站在前台？这是因为你很难走到我身边。他们想把摄像机放在厨房里，这样我们就看不到了。他们会透过百叶窗进行拍摄。这将是一场超级机密的特工偷拍。那是最佳位置。
We worked out exactly how I would stand with the phone. And then they said, now we want you to go back to your trailer and not leave until you're called. Oh, wow. And don't speak to John and just be alone. And so it was super secret. Yes. They, they talk about this in the DVD commentary guys.
我们精确地计算了我拿着电话站立的姿势。然后他们说，现在我们要你回到化妆车里，在被叫到之前不准离开。哦，哇。而且不要和约翰说话，就一个人待着。所以这是超级机密的。是的。他们在DVD花絮里谈过这件事，伙计们。
I wasn't there, but I listened to the DVD commentary and they wanted to keep you guys apart. Yeah. That's something that they talked about. My favorite thing is like, I'm reminiscing about it now with you and I remember one time talking to Brian about it years later and I was like, oh man, I remember that was the last thing we shot that day and he goes, no, it was not. And I was like, what are you talking about?
我当时不在，但我听了DVD花絮，他们想让你们两个分开。是的。这是他们讨论过的事。我最喜欢的部分是，我现在跟你一起回忆这件事，我记得多年前有一次跟布莱恩聊起这事，我说，哦天哪，我记得那是那天我们拍的最后一个镜头，而他说，不，根本不是。我说，你在说什么呢？
And he goes, we were all in our trailers like, oh God, let's go. We were in our trailers for like three hours. Like I took a nap. Someone was like, what is happening? My favorite is that that was the last thing we did that day. Me too. And Brian was like 1000% not all of us were in our trailers being like, you've got to be kidding me with these two.
然后他说，我们都在自己的化妆车里想着，哦天哪，快走吧。我们在化妆车里待了大概三个小时。我甚至小睡了一会儿。有人在问，到底怎么回事？我最喜欢的是，那确实是我们那天拍的最后一个镜头。我也是。布莱恩当时说百分之千不是，我们所有人都待在自己的化妆车里想，这两个人真是开玩笑开大了。
Oh no. Oh no. I thought it was the end of the day. That's what I said to Brian. Oh my goodness. He's right. But I don't know. You guys, it was such an important scene.
哦不。哦不。我以为那是收工的时候。我就是这么对布莱恩说的。哦天哪。他是对的。但不知道为什么。伙计们，这真的是一场非常重要的戏。
They had to find it and in the commentary, they talk about how they wanted the first time that John as Jim saw Pam was in that moment on action. Yeah. They never rehearsed it on the stage together. And then I remember they brought me to set and all the lights were dim. There was no one around. It was super creepy. Yeah.
他们必须找到那种感觉，花絮里提到，他们希望约翰饰演的吉姆第一次见到帕姆正是在导演喊“开始”的那一瞬间。是的。他们从未一起在片场排练过。然后我记得他们把我带到片场，所有的灯光都调暗了。四周空无一人。超级诡异。是的。
That was creepy. Yeah. That's right. So there was nothing. And they were like, John, please move to the entrance. I was like, who is that? Is that the devil? Who just saw me?
那确实很诡异。是的。没错。所以什么都没有。然后他们说，约翰，请移动到入口处。我在想，那是谁？那是魔鬼吗？刚才谁看见我了？
In your mind, John, it's like, slow down. Yeah, but it's super like scary, like weird. And then Ken, I think, and Greg, were hiding maybe in the conference room in the very back corner with a little thing, like a little, I don't know, what is that, like a handheld video monitor that they could see what the camera is shooting. We only used one camera. It was only the camera in the kitchen. So it was a one shot.
在你的脑海里，约翰，就好像，慢下来。是的，但这超级像恐怖片，感觉很诡异。然后肯，我想，还有格雷格，可能躲在最里面角落里的会议室里，拿着一个小东西，一个小，我不知道，那是什么，就像是一个手持视频监视器，他们可以通过它看到摄像机在拍什么。我们只用了一台摄像机。只有厨房里的那一台摄像机。所以这是一个长镜头。
There was no way to cut. We had to get it all in one shot. And I remember I'm doing the bit with my mom on the phone and then you walked in and we shot the kiss and then we're staring at each other. And Ken said, cut. And do you remember Greg, do you remember Greg running out of the conference room, like clapping his hands and he was like, yes, he was like, he was giddy. He was like, yes, he was like, it was so good.
根本没法剪辑。我们必须一次性把它拍完。我记得我正拿着电话跟妈妈演那场戏，然后你走进来，我们拍了那个吻，接着我们互相对视。肯喊了，卡。你还记得格雷格吗，你还记得格雷格从会议室里跑出来，拍着手，他当时就像是，耶，他当时兴高采烈的。他就像是，耶，他当时说，太棒了。
It was so good. It was how many takes of that did we do three? Wow. I only did. Greg in the commentaries said that he, I'm sorry, I wrote it down. Greg said he picked the last tape. The last take was his favorite. Oh, interesting.
太棒了。那个镜头我们到底拍了多少遍，三次？哇。我只拍了。格雷格在花絮里说他，对不起，我记下来了。格雷格说他选了最后一个镜头。最后一个镜头是他的最爱。哦，有趣。
Well, Ken Quapis and Kent Zabornak both confirm we only did three takes of the scene. And Ken said that Greg wanted to keep doing it over and over and over again. And Ken had to convince him that we had it. Wow. But Greg was like, it's just so good. It's just so good. And he wanted to keep doing it. And Ken was like, no, we're going to wear him out.
好吧，肯·夸帕斯和肯·赞博纳克都证实我们这场戏只拍了三次。肯说格雷格本来想一遍又一遍、没完没了地拍下去。肯不得不说服他，我们已经拍好了。哇。但格雷格却说，真的是太棒了。真的是太棒了。他还想继续拍。而肯则说，不，我们会把他们累坏的。
We're going to wear him out. That's obviously where the voice was coming from. And I imagine Greg just being like, Darren's for me. And you're like, what? You can't say that. Awkward. Awkward. That's so weird.
我们会把他们累坏的。声音显然就是从那儿传出来的。我能想象到格雷格当时就像是在说，太适合我了。而你却在想，什么？你不能这么说。尴尬。尴尬。这也太诡异了。
Oh my gosh. One other thing in the DVD commentary you guys, I thought was really cool is that Randall Einhorn said that he really wanted it to end so that you couldn't see Pam's face. So you never knew what her reaction was after that. That's right. So that was really thought out that, Jenna, you never looked around like you were facing this one way and camera never saw your face after the kiss. Yeah, that was part of what he argued for only using one camera.
哦天哪。关于DVD花絮，伙计们，我还觉得很酷的一点是，兰德尔·伊恩霍恩说他真的很想让镜头在这个场景结束时看不到帕姆的脸。这样你就永远不知道她在那之后的反应是什么。没错。所以这是经过深思熟虑的，珍娜，你从来没有四处张望，就像你一直面向一个方向，摄像机在吻戏之后也从未拍到你的脸。是的，这就是他坚持只使用一台摄像机的理由之一。
That there was some discussion that another camera would come around by the front door and capture Pam's side of everything and sneak in. But he was like, no, I think we only managed to get one shot of this. So you don't know. It was amazing. Yeah. Crazy. It was beautiful, you guys.
当时有人讨论说，另一台摄像机可以绕到前门旁边，捕捉帕姆面对这一切时的侧脸并偷拍进去。但他却说，不，我觉得我们只能拍到这一个镜头。所以你无从得知。太棒了。是的。疯狂。太美了，伙计们。
You guys crushed it. It was the most fun ever to talk about this. Yeah. I mean, it was fun to reminisce. You guys, guys, congratulations on this podcast. It is so much fun and I don't think two other people could have done it. I mean, you guys do such a good job. Aw, you're so nice.
你们俩太棒了。聊起这些真是太有趣了。是的。我是说，回忆往事很有趣。伙计们，祝贺你们的这个播客。真的太有趣了，我觉得不会有另外两个人能做到这一点。我是说，你们俩做得太棒了。啊，你太好了。
Thank you. Thanks so much. I don't know if there's two people from our show who like talking as much as us. Do you remember? Who talk constantly. Do you remember? Brian's at home going like, we know that. True.
谢谢。非常感谢。我不知道我们剧组里是不是还有两个人像我们一样这么爱聊天。你记得吗？一直在聊天的人。你记得吗？布莱恩在家肯定会想，我们早就知道了。真的。
You're like, Brian, jeez, settle down. Do you remember how Rand would make fun of us? He would say, there they go. Like, we'd be like, yeah. What more could you possibly have to say to one another? I don't know. God. Our curmudgeon.
你就像是，布莱恩，天哪，冷静点。你还记得兰德尔是怎么取笑我们的吗？他会说，他们又来了。就像，我们会说，是啊。你们俩之间到底还有什么好说的？我不知道。天哪。我们的老顽固。
Our curmudgeon. Aw, thank you, John. I love you both so much. Thank you so much for doing. Thanks for having me. We love you, John. Thanks for coming on. That was so great.
我们的老顽固。啊，谢谢你，约翰。我也非常爱你们俩。非常感谢你们来参加。谢谢邀请我。我们也爱你，约翰。谢谢你来做客。真是太棒了。
We hope you enjoyed it as much as we did. Yeah. Thank you, John. John Krasinski. You're the best. He is the best. He is the best. He is the best.
我们希望你们和我们一样享受其中。是的。谢谢你，约翰。约翰·卡拉辛斯基。你是最棒的。他真的是最棒的。他真的是最棒的。他真的是最棒的。
But Jenna, before we say goodbye, there are one or two moments that fans wrote in about. We have to talk about the phone call between Pam and her mom. Yeah. We have to talk about this moment. Yes. We got so much mail about this. Erin Louise, Matt Loveless, Mrs. Prince, Brianna and EJ. They all wanted to know if there was another side to this phone call.
不过珍娜，在我们说再见之前，还有一两个粉丝来信提到的时刻。我们必须聊聊帕姆和她妈妈之间的那通电话。是的。我们必须聊聊这个时刻。是的。我们收到了雪片般关于这通电话的信件。埃琳·露易丝、马特·洛夫莱斯、普林斯太太、布里安娜和EJ。他们都想知道这通电话的另一头到底有没有人。
Well, I'll tell you this, guys. There was no one on the other line. Jenna! I was just pretending. And the Emmy goes to Jenna Fisher. Wow. Oh, thank you. That's some good phone talk, lady.
好吧，我来告诉你们，伙计们。电话那头根本没有人。珍娜！我只是在假装。而艾美奖得主是——珍娜·费舍尔。哇。哦，谢谢。这电话打得真好，女士。
Yeah. No one was there. No one was there. I invented in my head what the dialogue was. Yeah. And I had written it down in my script for what I thought my mom was saying to me so that I would have good reactions. And I was going through it in my head as I was doing the scene.
是的。根本没人。根本没人。我自己在脑海里编造了对话内容。是的。我在剧本里写下了我认为我妈妈对我说的话，这样我才能做出好的反应。在演这场戏的时候，我在脑海里把这些过了一遍。
That's me applauding my BFF. Oh, my gosh. Thank you. Yeah. So there was one line in particular that everyone honed in on, which is when Pam says, yeah, I think I am. Yeah. What was she responding to?
这就是我在为我最好的朋友鼓掌。哦，天哪。谢谢。是的。所以其中有一句台词格外引人注目，就是帕姆说，是的，我想我是。是的。她当时是在回应什么？
I mean, I know what I thought. I think I know what all the fans think. What do you think? I think I am in love with him. That is what I had written in my script, that my mom asked me, well, sweetie, are you in love with him? Yeah. And that I answered, yeah, mom, I think I am.
我是说，我知道我是怎么想的。我想我知道所有粉丝是怎么想的。你觉得呢？我想我是爱上他了。这就是我在剧本里写的内容，我妈妈问我，那么，亲爱的，你爱上他了吗？是的。然后我回答，是的，妈妈，我想我是。
Oof. Yeah. Oh, Pam. And then we got a fan question. A lot of people actually asked this question. Alyssa Dunn, Carrie Harvey, and more wanted to know if we knew what the next season would bring to the Jim Pam storyline when we shot those scenes in the parking lot and in the office.
噢。是的。哦，帕姆。然后我们收到了一个粉丝提问。实际上有很多人都问了这个问题。艾莉森·邓恩、凯莉·哈维以及更多人想知道，当我们在停车场和办公室拍摄那些场景时，我们是否知道下一季会给吉姆和帕姆的故事线带来什么。
Right. No, we did not. We were not told what would happen to them. It was a cliffhanger to the cast as well. I have to think that Greg probably had a few ideas and didn't want to tell us anything until it would become more concrete for him, what the plan was, you know? Mm-hmm. I would think.
没错。不，我们不知道。没有人告诉我们他们会怎么样。这对演员们来说也是一个悬念。我得说格雷格可能有一些想法，但直到他自己对整体计划有了更具象的构想之前，他什么都不想告诉我们，你知道的？嗯哼。我想是这样的。
I think he had an idea that they were going to have Jim go to Stanford. Well, yeah. But a few weeks before we went back into production for the season three, I did get called in to do a bunch of chemistry read auditions with possible Karen's. Yeah. And that was my first insight into what was going to happen in season three. Mm. Oh, that's juicy.
我想他当时已经有了让吉姆去斯坦福的想法。好吧，是的。但在我们重回第三季拍摄的前几周，我确实被叫去和所有可能的“凯伦”人选一起试戏，做化学反应测试。是的。那是我对第三季即将发生的事情的最初了解。嗯。哦，这太有爆料性了。
That would have been, that's like good intel back then because we were all clueless. We didn't know what was going to happen. I think another cliffhanger is, you know, obviously the Dwight Angelo was happening with them. But then also what is going to happen with Jan and Michael because you see that Jan actually did pack an overnight bag in her car. Yes. Yes.
那在当时绝对算得上是好情报了，因为我们当时都一无所知。我们根本不知道会发生什么。我想另一个悬念是，你知道的，显然德怀特和安吉拉之间发生的事。但接着还有简和迈克尔之间会发生什么，因为你可以看到简其实在车里收拾了一个过夜包。是的。是的。
Yeah. As she's leaving, the camera finds this overnight bag. She was 100% planning to hook up with Michael. Yeah. And just sleep over at his place, which is a big deal. Well, I did hear in the DVD commentary that it was this episode that Malora Hardin and David Denman became series regulars. So we knew that they were going to be coming back, but we didn't know how.
是的。当她离开时，摄像机发现了这个过夜包。她百分之百是打算和迈克尔发生点什么。是的。并且直接在他家过夜，这可是一件大事。不过我在DVD花絮里听说，正是从这一集开始，梅洛拉·哈丁和大卫·丹曼成为了剧集的常规演员。所以我们知道他们会回归，但不知道会以什么形式。
Wow. There we go. Wow. There we go, guys. That was a big, big episode. We hope you enjoyed it. We certainly enjoyed getting to watch it again and talk to John and all the cast members we texted and Kintopedia.
哇。原来如此。哇。就是这样，伙计们。那真是一集非常、非常重大的剧集。我们希望你们喜欢它。我们再次观看并与约翰以及我们发短信的所有演员和肯·夸帕斯交流，确实感到非常开心。
Thank you so much for giving us such great behind the scenes moments. Yes. And guys, after we did that interview with John, Angelo and I were a part of his show Some Good News. It was so much fun. First of all, my family and I are such huge fans of Some Good News. We've watched every episode and what John is doing, the goodness he's putting out there is so wonderful.
非常感谢你们带给我们如此精彩的幕后时刻。是的。而且伙计们，在我们对约翰进行完采访之后，安吉拉和我参加了他的节目《一些好消息》。真的太有趣了。首先，我和我的家人都是《一些好消息》的超级粉丝。我们看过每一集，约翰所做的事情，他所散播的善意是如此美好。
And Jenna, wasn't it a blast? It was so much fun. If you guys haven't seen it, you have to check it out. There's this couple, their names are John and Susan Lush, they're from Maryland. And when they got engaged, they reenacted Jim and Pam's engagement at the gas station. But then because of the pandemic, their May wedding was canceled. So John surprised them. We might have recreated the Dance Down the Isle from Jim and Pam's wedding and it was
而且珍娜，当时是不是超级开心？真的太有趣了。如果你们还没看过，一定要去看看。有这样一对夫妇，他们的名字叫约翰和苏珊·勒什，他们来自马里兰州。当他们订婚时，他们在加油站重现了吉姆和帕姆的求婚场景。但后来因为疫情，他们五月份的婚礼被取消了。于是约翰给了他们一个惊喜。我们可能重现了吉姆和帕姆婚礼上的走道舞蹈，那真是
just so much fun and such a wonderful thing to be a part of. Yeah. The thing that John is doing with that, it's just, it's great. He's bringing some light and love to the world and John, we love you. We love you. And you guys, we will see you next week with Can You Believe It? The first episode of Season 3. Gay Witch Hunt.
太有趣了，能参与其中感觉太棒了。是的。约翰通过那个节目所做的事，真的很棒。他给世界带来了一些光亮和爱，约翰，我们爱你。我们爱你。伙计们，我们下周见，准备好迎接了吗？第三季的第一集。《同性恋女巫大搜捕》。
Can you believe we're on Season 3, Angela? I can't believe it. I can't believe it. And thank you guys so much for being along with us for the ride. We will see you next week, Season 3. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher.
安吉拉，你能相信我们已经拍到第三季了吗？我简直不敢相信。我简直不敢相信。非常感谢你们一路上对我们的支持。我们下周见，第三季。感谢收听“办公室女士”。“办公室女士”由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利联合制作。我们的执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。
Our producer is Cassie Jerkin. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubakow. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的制片人是卡西·杰金。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，助理制片人是艾恩斯利·布巴科夫。我们的主题曲是里德·布拉顿创作的《橡胶树》。想要收听无广告版的“办公室女士”，请访问StitcherPremium.com。免费试用Stitcher Premium一个月，请使用优惠码：Office。本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。